Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone thank you again for
showing up so tonight we're going to
finish off the story of Noah and also
the story of the Tower of Babel and I
don't think that'll take very long and
then we're going to turn to the
Abrahamic stories and they're a very
complex set of stories they sit between
the earliest stories in Genesis that I
would say end with the Tower of Babel
and then the stories of Moses which are
extraordinarily well-developed Abrahamic
stories there's a whole sequence of them
multiple stories conjoined together and
there I found them very daunting they're
very difficult to understand and so I'm
going to stumble through them the best
that I can I would say that's that's
probably the best way to think about
this because they have a narrative
content that's quite strange I was
reading a book while doing this called
the disappearance of God that I found
quite helpful and the author of that
book argues that one of the things that
happens in the Old Testament is that God
is very manifest at the beginning in
terms of personal appearances even and
then that proclivity fades away as the
Old Testament develops and there's a
parallel development that it's maybe
maybe causally linked I'm not exactly
sure how to conceptualize it but that
appears to be causally linked is that
the stories about individuals become
more and more well-developed so it says
in
it's as if as God fades away so to speak
the individual becomes more and more
manifest and there's a statement in the
Old Testament the location of which I
don't recall but I'll tell you about it
in future lectures where God essentially
tells whoever he's speaking with and I
don't remember who that is that he's
going to disappear and let man
essentially go his own way
and see what happens not a complete
disappearance but maybe a
transformations is something that modern
people regard more as a psychological
phenomena rather than the sort of
objective entity that God seems to be in
the beginning of the biblical stories
and so I've been wrestling with that a
lot because the notion that God I got
appears to Abraham multiple times and
that's not a concept that's easy for
modern people to to grasp in for us
generally speaking apart from say issues
of faith God is it some thing someone
who makes himself personally manifest in
our lives he doesn't appear to us that's
I suppose why the question of belief is
so paramount for modern people I presume
that if God had within the habit of
appearing to you you likely wouldn't
have a problem with belief I mean it
might be more complicated than that but
that's how it seems to me and so when we
read stories about God making himself
manifest either to a nation say in the
case of Israel or to individuals it's
not easy to understand it's not easy to
understand why people would write
stories like that if they thought like
we thought and I mean it really it
wasn't that long ago that the Bible was
written say from a biological
perspective it's really only yesterday
it's a couple thousand years say four
thousand years something like that
that's not very long ago from a
biological perspective it's it's nothing
so the first thing I tried to do is to
see if I could figure out how to
understand that and so else
the lecture once we finish the the
remains of the story of Noah
I'll start the lecture with a with an
attempt to situate the Abrahamic stories
in a context that might make them more
accessible these two contexts that work
for me to make them more accessible
let's conclude the Noah story first
however when we ended last time the ark
had come to its resting place and Noah
and his family had debarked and so this
is the stories of what occurs
immediately after afterwards it's a very
short story but I think it's it's very
relevant for both of these stories the
Tower of Babel is well very relevant for
our current times and the sons of Noah
that went forth of the ark were shem and
ham and Japheth and ham is the father of
canaan these are the three sons of Noah
and of them was the whole earth
overspread and Noah began to be a
husbandman and he planted a vine yard
and he drank of the wine and was drunken
and he was uncovered within his tent and
ham the father of Canaan saw the
nakedness of his father and told his two
brethren without and Shem and Japheth
took a garment and laid upon both their
shoulders and went backward and covered
the nakedness of their father and their
faces were backward and they saw not
their fathers nakedness and Noah awoke
from his wine and knew what his younger
son had done unto him and he said curse
had to be Canaan a servant of servants
shall he be unto his brethren and he
said blessed shall be the Lord God of
Shem and Canaan shall be his servant and
God shall enlarge Japheth and he shall
dwell in the tents of Shem and Canaan
shall be his servant and Noah lived
after the flood three hundred and fifty
years and all the days of Noah were 950
years and he died and the whole earth
was of one language and of one speech
okay so
I remember thinking about this story
it's got to be 30 years ago and I think
the meaning of the story stood out for
me sometimes when you read complicated
material sometimes a piece of it will
stand out it's for some reason it's like
it glitters I suppose that might be one
way of thinking about it it's it you're
in sync with it and you can understand
what it means I've really experienced
that reading the DAO de Jing which is
document I would really like to do a
lecture on at some point because some of
the verses I don't understand but others
stand right out and I can understand
them and I think I understood what this
part of the story of Noah meant and I
think it means you know we talked a
little bit about what nakedness meant in
the story of Adam and Eve and the idea
essentially was that to know yourself
naked is to become aware of your
vulnerability the physical your physical
boundaries in time and space and your
your your physiological your fundamental
physiological insufficiencies as they
mate might be judged by others so
there's biological insufficiency that
sort of built into you because you're a
fragile mortal vulnerable half insane
creature and that's that's just an
existential truth and then of course
even merely as a human being even with
all those faults there are faults that
you have that are particular to you that
might be judged harshly by the group
well might be will definitely be judged
harshly by the group and so to become
aware of your nakedness is to become
self-conscious and and to and to know
your limits and to know your
vulnerability and that's what is
revealed to ham when he comes across his
father naked and so the question is what
does it mean to see your father naked
and it seems to me and especially in an
inappropriate manner like this it it
it's it's it's as if ham he does the
same thing that happens in the
Mesopotamian creation myth when when
time out and absolute give rise to the
first gods
there there the father of the eventual
deity of redemption
Marduk they're very careless and noisy
and they kill apps ooh their father and
attempt to inhabit his corpse and that
makes timeout enraged and so she bursts
forth from the darkness to to do them in
it's like a precursor to the flood story
or an analogue to the flood story and I
see the same thing happening here with
ham is that he's is insufficiently
respectful of his father and the
question is exactly what does the father
represent and you can say well there's
there's there's the father that you have
and that's a human being that's the
demand like other men a man among men
but then there's the farther as such and
that's the spirit of the father and
insofar as you have a father you have
both at the same time you have the
personal father that's a man among other
men just like anyone others father but
insofar as that man is your father that
means that he's something different than
just another person and what he is is
the incarnation of the spirit of the
Father and to see that to take it to
what to disrespect that carelessly maybe
even he's like no one makes a mistake
right he produces wine and gets himself
drunk and you might say well you know if
he sprawled out there for everyone to
see it's hardly hams fault if he
stumbles across them but the book is
laying out a danger and the danger is
that well maybe you catch your father at
his most vulnerable moment and if you're
disrespectful
then you transgress against the spirit
of the Father and if you transgress
against the spirit of father and lose
spirit of the father and lose respect
for the spirit of the father then that
is likely to transform you into a slave
that's a very interesting idea and I
think it's particularly interesting
maybe not particularly interesting but
it's it's particularly germane I think
to our current cultural situation
because I think that we're pushed
constantly to see the nakedness of our
Father so to speak because of the
intense criticism that's
directed towards our culture and the
patriarch of culture so to speak we're
constantly exposing its weaknesses and
vulnerabilities and let's say nakedness
and there's nothing wrong with criticism
but the thing about criticism is the
purpose of criticism is to separate the
wheat from the chaff it's not to burn
everything to the ground right it's to
say well we're going to carefully look
at this we're going to carefully
differentiate we're going to keep what's
good and we're going to move away from
what's bad but the point of the
criticism isn't to identify everything
is bad it's to separate what's good from
what's bad so that you can retain what's
good and move towards it and and to be
careless at that is deadly because
you're inhabited by the spirit of the
Father right insofar as you're a
cultural construction which of course is
something that the that the postmodern
neo-marxists are absolutely emphatic
about you're a cultural construction
insofar as you're a cultural
construction then you're inhabited by
the spirit of the Father and to be
disrespectful towards that means to
undermine the very structure that makes
you not all of what you are certainly
certainly not all of what you are but a
good portion of what you are insofar as
you're a socialized cultural entity and
if you pull out if you pull the
foundation out from underneath that what
do you have left
you can hardly manage on your own you
know it's just not possible
you're a cultural creation and so pam
makes this desperate error and is
careless about exposing himself to the
vulnerability of his father something
like that he doesn't without sufficient
respect and the judgment is that not
only will he be a slave but so all of
his descendants and he's contrasted with
the other two sons who I suppose are
willing to give their father the benefit
of the doubt something like that and so
when they see him in a compromising
position they handle it with respect and
and and don't capitalize on it and maybe
that makes them strong that's what it
seems to me and so I think that's what
that story means
it has something to do with respect you
know and the funny thing about having
respect for your culture and I suppose
that's partly why I'm doing the biblical
stories is because they're part of a
they're part of my culture they're part
of our culture perhaps but they're
certainly part of my culture and it
seems to me that it's worthwhile to
treat that with respect to see what you
can glean from it and and not kick it
when it's down let's say so and so
that's how the story of no ends you know
and the thing too is Noah is actually a
pretty decent incarnation of the spirit
of the Father that which I suppose is
one of the things that makes hams
misstep more egregious is that I mean
Noah just built an ark and got everybody
through the flood man you know it's not
so bad and so maybe the fact that he
happened to drink too much wine one day
wasn't enough to justify humiliating him
and you know I don't think it's pushing
the limits of symbolic interpretation to
note on a daily basis that we're all
contained in an ark right and that's the
ark that you could think about that as
the ark that's been bequeathed to us by
our forefathers that's the tremendous
infrastructure that we inhabit that we
take for granted because it works so
well that protects us from things that
we can't even imagine and we don't have
to imagine because we're so well
protected and so one of the things
that's really struck me hard I would say
about the disintegration and corruption
of the universities is the absolute
ingratitude that goes along with that
you know what
criticism as I said it's a fine thing if
it's done in the spirit in a proper
spirit and that's the spirit of
separating the wheat from the chaff but
it needs to be accompanied by gratitude
and it does seem to me that anyone who
lives in in the West in the Western
culture at this time in history and in
this place and who hasn't
Dainius ly grateful for that is is
half-blind
at least because it's never been better
than this and it could be so much worse
and it's highly likely that it will be
so much worse because for most of human
history so much worse is the norm so
then there's this little story that
crops up that seems in some ways
unrelated to everything that's gone
before it but I think it's also an
extremely profound little story it took
me a long time to figure it out it's the
Tower of Babel and it came to pass as
they journeyed from the east that they
found a plain in the land of Shinar and
dwelt there that's Noah's descendants
and the whole earth was of one language
and of one speech and it came to pass as
they journeyed from the east that they
found a plain in the land of Shinar and
they dwelt there and they said to one
another go let us make brick and burn
them thoroughly and they had brick for
stone and slime they head for mortar so
they're establishing a city and they
said go let us build a city and a tower
whose top may reach unto heaven and let
us make a name lest we be scattered
abroad upon the face of the earth and
the Lord came down to see the city in
the tower which the children of men
built and the Lord said Behold the
people is one and they all have one
language and now this they begin to do
and now nothing will be restrained from
them which they have imagined to do go
to let us go down and there confound
their language that they may not
understand one another's speech so the
Lord scattered them abroad from thence
upon the face of all the earth and they
left off to build the city therefore is
the name of it called Babel because the
Lord did there confound the language of
all the earth and from thence did the
Lord scattered them abroad upon the face
of all the earth it's a very difficult
story to understand and it's on the face
of it it doesn't seem to show God in a
very good light although that happens
fairly frequently in the Old Testament
as far as I can tell but you know the
thing to do if you're reading in the
spirit of the text let's say is to
remember that it's God that you're
talking about and so even though you
might think that he's appearing in a bad
light your duty as a reader I suppose is
to assume that you're wrong and that
what he did was right and then you're
supposed to figure out well how could it
possibly be right because the axiomatic
presupposition is that it's God and
whatever he does is right and you might
say well you can disagree with that and
it's it's also the case that some of the
people that God talks to in the Old
Testament actually disagree with him and
convinced him to alter his actions but
the point still remains that it's God
and if he's doing it then by definition
there's a good reason there's an idea
much later that John Milton develops in
in Paradise Lost which is an amazing
poem and it's it's it's a it's it's a
profound enough foam so that it's almost
been incorporated into the biblical
structure I would say so the corpus of
Christianity post Milton was saturated
by the miltonic stories of Satan's
rebellion none of us in the in the in
the biblical texts or it's only hinted
at in very brief passages and Milton
wrote his poem to justify the word the
ways of God to man which is quite an
ambition really it's an amazing profound
ambition to try to produce something to
produce a literary work that justifies
being to human beings because that's
what Milton was trying to do so one of
my readers here sent me a link the other
day for viewers to a work of philosophy
by an Australian philosopher whose name
I don't remember who basically wrote a
book saying that being as such human
experience is so corrupt and so
permeated by suffering that it would be
better if it had never existed at all
sort of the ultimate expression of
nihilism and Goethe in in Faust his
methods awfully who's a satanic
character obviously has that as a credo
that's that Satan's fundamental
motivation is his objection to creation
itself is that creation is so flawed and
so rife with suffering that it would be
better if it had never existed at all
and so that's his motivation for
attempting to continue to destroy it but
in Milton's Paradise Lost Satan has an
intellectual figure and you see that
motif emerged very frequently by the way
in popular culture so for example in the
Lion King the figure of Skaar who's a
satanic figure is also hyper
intellectual and that's very common that
you know it's the evil scientist motif
or the or the evil advisor to the king
the same motif it encapsulate something
about rationality and it what it seems
to encapsulate is the idea that
rationality like Satanist is the highest
angel in God's heavenly kingdom it's a
psychological idea you know that the
most powerful sub element of the human
psyche is the intellect and and it's the
thing that shines out above all within
the domain of humanity and maybe across
the domain of life itself the human
intellect there's something absolutely
remarkable about it but it has a flaw
and the flaw is that it tends to fall in
love with its own productions and to
assume that their total solzhenitsyn
when he was writing the Gulag
Archipelago had a warning about that
with regards to totalitarian ideology
and he said that the price of selling
your god-given soul to the entrapments
of human dogma was slavery and death
essentially and Satan in may in Milton's
Paradise Lost
Satan decides that he can do without the
transcendent he can do without God and
that's why he foment rebellion it's
something like that and the consequence
of that the immediate consequence from
Nolan's perspective was that as soon as
Satan
decided that what he knew was sufficient
that he could do without the
transcendent which he might think about
as the domain outside of what you know
something like that immediately he was
in hell and when I read Paradise Lost I
was studying totalitarianism and I
thought you know the poet the true poet
like a prophet if someone who has
intimations of the future and maybe
that's because the poetic mind the
philosophical or prophetic mind is a
pattern detector and and there are
people who can detect the underlying
it's like the malady of a nation melody
is in song the song of a nation and can
see how it's going to develop across the
centuries you see this you see that
Nietzsche because Nietzsche for example
in the mid you know in 1860 or so I mean
he prophesied what was going to happen
in the 20th century said that he said
specifically that the spectre of
communism would kill millions of people
in the 20th century it's amazing
prophecy he said that in the notes that
became will to power and Dostoyevsky was
of the same sort of mind someone who was
in touch enough with the fundamental
patterns of human movement that they
could extrapolate out into the future
and see what was coming and I mean some
people are very good at detecting
patterns you know and and uh Milton I
think was of that sort and I think he
had intimations of what was coming as
human rationality became more and more
powerful and technology became more and
more powerful and the information was
that we would produce systems that
dispensed with God that were completely
rational and completely total that would
immediately turn everything they touched
into something indistinguishable from
hell and then Milton's warning was
embodied in the poem is that the
rational mind that generates a
production and then worships it as if
it's absolute immediately occupies hell
so what does that have to do with the
Tower of Babel we know it back into 2008
when the when we had that economic
collapse
the strange idea emerged politically and
that was the idea of too big to fail and
I thought about that idea for a long
time because I thought there's something
deeply wrong with that is one of the
things that made Marx wrong was Marx
believed that capital would flow into
the hands of fewer and fewer people and
that the dissociation between the rich
and the poor would become more extreme
as capitalism developed and like so many
things that Marx said that's it's kind
of true it's kind of true in that the
distribution of wealth and in fact a
distribution of anything that's produced
follows a purrito pattern and the Prieta
pattern basically is that a small
proportion of people end up with the
bulk of the goods and it isn't just
money it's it's anything that people
produce creatively ends up in that
distribution and that's actually the
economists call that the Matthieu
principle and they take that from a
statement in the New Testament and the
statement is to those who have
everything more will be given and from
those who have nothing everything will
be taken and it's it's a map of the
manner in which the world manifests
itself where human creative production
is involved and the map seems to
indicate that as you start to produce
and you're successful the probability
that you will continue to be successful
or accelerate increases as you're
successful and as you fail the
probability that you will fail starts to
accelerate so if your progress to life
looks like this or like this something
like that and the reason that Marx was
right was because he noted that as a
feature of the capitalist system the
reason that he was wrong is that it's
not a feature that's specific to a
capitalist system it's a feature that's
general to all systems of creative
production that are known and so it's
like a natural law and it's enough of a
natural law by the way that the
distribution of wealth can be modeled by
physical models using the same equations
that govern the distribution of gas
molecules in a vacuum so it's a really
profound it's a fundamentally profound
observation
about the world way the world lays
itself out and it's problematic because
if resources accrue unfairly to a small
minority of people and there's a natural
law like element to that that has to be
dealt with from a social perspective
because if the inequality becomes too
extreme then the whole system will
destabilize and so you can have an
intelligent discussion about how to
mitigate the effects of the transfer of
creative production into the hands of a
small number of people now the other
reason however having said that the
other reason that Marx was wrong there's
a number of them one is that even though
creative products end up in the hands of
a small number of people it's not the
same people consistently across time
it's the same proportion of people and
that's not the same thing
you know like imagine that there's water
going down a drain and you say well look
at the spiral it's permanent you think
well the spiral is permanent but the
water molecules aren't they're moving
through it and it's the same in some
sense with the Pareto distribution is
that there's a 1% and there's always a
1% but it's not the same people
it's the stability of it differs from
culture to culture but there's a lot of
movement in the upper 1% a tremendous
amount of movement and one of the
reasons for that movement is that things
get large and then they get too large
and then they collapse and so in 2008
when the politicians said too big to
fail they got something truly backwards
as far as I can tell and that was with a
reverse the statement was reversed it
should have been so big it had to fail
and that's what I think the story of the
Tower of Babel is about it's it's a
warning against the expansion of the
system until it encompasses everything
it's a warning against totalitarian
presumption so what happens for example
when people set out to build the Tower
of Babel as they want to build a
structure that reaches to heaven right
so the idea is that it can it can it can
replace it can replace the role of God
it's something like that it can erase
the distinction between Earth and heaven
and so there's a utopian kind of vision
there as well as we can build a
structure that's so large and
encompassing that that that it can
replace heaven itself
that's an interesting the fact that that
doesn't work and that God objects to it
is also extraordinarily interesting and
it's an indication to me of the
unbelievable profundity of these stories
it's like I think one thing we should
have learned from the 20th century but
of course didn't was that there's
something extraordinary dangerous about
totalitarian utopian visions
that's something Dostoevsky wrote about
by the way in his great book notes from
underground because dossiers Keats
figured out by the early 1900's that
there was something very very
pathological about a utopian vision of
perfection that it was profoundly
anti-human and and notes in notes from
underground he demolishes the notion of
utopia one of the things he says that I
loved it's so brilliant said imagine
that you brought the socialist utopia
into being and Dostoyevsky says and that
human beings had nothing to do except
eat drink and busy themselves with the
continuation of the species he said that
the first thing that would happen under
circumstances like that would be that
human beings would go mad and break the
system smash it just so that something
unexpected and crazy could happen
because human beings don't want youto be
in comfort and certainty they want
adventure and chaos and uncertainty and
so that the very notion of a utopia was
anti-human because we're not built for
static utopia we're built for a dynamic
situation where there's demands placed
on us and where there's the optimal
amount of uncertainty
well we know what happened in the 20th
century as a consequence of the
widespread promulgation of utopian
schemes and what happened was a ham on a
scale that had never been matched in the
entire history of humanity and that's
really saying something because there
was plenty of mayhem before the 20th
century I guess there wasn't as much
industrial clout behind it and so so
early you see so early in the biblical
narrative you have a warning against
hubris and and some indication that
properly functioning systems have an
appropriate scale I read an article in
The Economist magazine this week about
the rise of nationalist movements all
over the world as a counterbalance to
globalization maybe it's most market
with the European Economic Community and
The Economist writers were curious about
why that counter movement has been
developing but it seems to me that it's
also a Tower of Babel phenomena is that
and maybe this is most evident in the
European Economic Community to bring all
of that multiplicity under the what
would you call it under the umbrella of
a single unity is to simultaneously
erect a system where the top is so far
from the bottom that the bottom has no
connection to the top you know your your
your social systems have to be large
enough so they protect you but small
enough so that you have a place in them
and it seems to me perhaps that's what's
happened in in places like the EEC is
that the distance between the typical
citizen and the bureaucracy that runs
the entire structure has got so great
that it's an element of East able
ization in and of itself and so people
revert back to say nationalistic
identities because it's something that
they can relate to
if there's a there's a history there and
a shared identity a genuine identity an
identity of language and tradition it's
not an artificial imposition from the
top
an artificial abstract imposition in in
the Egyptian creation method the version
I'm familiar with in the previous
creation that's the older one the
Mesopotamian creation myth mostly what
you see
menacing humanity is time at she's the
dragon of chaos and so that's nature
it's really it's really mother nature
red in tooth and claw but by the time
the Egyptians come along it isn't only
nature that threatens humanity it's the
social structure itself and so the
Egyptians had two deities that
represented the social structure and one
was Osiris who was like the spirit of
the Father he was a great hero who
established Egypt but became old and and
willfully blind and and and and senile
and he had an evil brother named Seth
and Seth was always conspiring to
overthrow him and because Osiris ignored
him long enough Seth did overthrow
chopped him into pieces and distributed
all around the kingdom and his son Horus
had to come back and fight
Osiris his son Horus had to come back
and defeat Seth to take the kingdom back
that's how that story ends but the
Egyptians seem to have realized maybe
because they had become bureaucratized
to quite a substantial degree that it
wasn't only nature that threatened
humankind it was also the proclivity of
human organizations to become too large
too unwieldy too deceitful and to
willfully blind and therefore liable to
collapse and again I see echoes of that
in the story of the Tower of Babel so
it's a calling for
a kind of humility of social engineering
one of the other things I've learned as
a social scientist and I've been warned
about this by I would say great social
scientists that you want to be very
careful about doing large-scale
experimentation with large scale systems
because the probability that if you
implement a scheme in a large-scale
social system that that scheme will have
the result you intended is negligible
what will happen will be something that
you don't intend and even worse
something that works at counter purposes
to your original intent and so and that
makes sense because if you have a very
very complex system and you perturb it
the probability that you can predict the
consequence of the perturbation is
extraordinary low obviously if the
system works though you think you
understand it because it works and so
you think it's simpler than it actually
is and so then you think that your model
of it is correct and then you think that
your manipulation of the model which
produces the outcome you model will be
the outcome that's actually produced in
the world that doesn't work at all I
thought about that an awful lot thinking
about how to remediate social systems
because obviously they need careful
attention and adjustment and it struck
me that the proper strategy for
implementing social change is to stay
within your domain of confidence and
that requires humility which is a virtue
that is never promoted in modern culture
I would say it's it's a virtue that you
can hardly even talk about but humility
means you're probably not as smart as
you think you are and you should be
careful and so then the question might
be well ok you should be careful but
perhaps you still want to do good you
want to make some positive changes how
can you be careful and do good and then
I would say well you try not to step out
the boundaries of your competence and
you start small and you start with
things that you actually could adjust
that you actually do understand that you
actually could fix I mentioned to you at
one point that one of the things Carl
Jung said was that modern men don't see
God because they don't look low enough
it's a very interesting phrase and one
of the things that I've been promoting I
suppose online is the idea that you
should restrict your attempts to fix
things to what's at hand so there's
probably things about you that you could
fix right things that you know that
aren't right not anyone else's opinion
your own opinion that aren't right you
can fix them maybe there's some things
that you could adjust in your family
that gets hard you have to have your act
together a lot before you can start to
adjust your family because things can
kick back on you really hard and you
think well it's hard to put yourself
together it's really hard to put your
family together why the hell do you
think you can put the world together
right because obviously the world is
more complicated than you and your
family and so if you if you're stymied
in your attempts even to set your own
house in order which of course you are
then you would think that what that
would do would be to make you very very
leery about announcing your broad-scale
plans for social revolution well it's a
peculiar thing because that isn't how it
works because people are much more
likely to announce their plans for
broad-scale social revolution than they
are to try to set themselves straight or
to set their family straight and I think
the reason for that is that as soon as
they try to set themselves straight or
their families the system immediately
kicks back at them right instantly
whereas if they announced their plans
for large-scale social revolution the
lag between the announcement and the
kickback is so long that they don't
recognize that there's any error there
and so you know you can get away with
being wrong if if nothing falls on you
for a while and so and it's also an
incitement to hubris because you can now
see your your plans for large-scale
social revolution and stand back and you
don't get hit by lightning and you think
well I might be right even though
you're not you're seriously not right I
might be right and then you think well
how wonderful is that especially if you
could do it without any real effort and
I really do think fundamentally I
believe that that's what the
universities teach students now that's
what they teach them to do I really
believe that and I think it's absolutely
appalling and I think it's horribly
dangerous because it's not that easy to
fix things especially if you don't
especially if you're not committed to it
and I think you know if you're committed
because what you try to do is you try to
straighten out your own life first and
that's enough like there's a I think
it's a statement in the New Testament
that it's I think it's in the New
Testament that it's more difficult to
rule yourself than to rule the city and
that's not a metaphor it's like all of
you who've made announcements to
yourself about changing your diet and
going to the gym every January know
perfectly well how difficult it is to
regulate your own impulses and to bring
yourself under the control of some what
would you say well-structured and
ethical attentive structure of values
it's extraordinarily difficult and so
people don't do it and instead they
wander off and I think they create
towers of Babel and the story indicates
well those things collapse under their
own weight and everyone goes their own
direction I think I see that happening
with the LGBT community I think because
one of the things I've noticed it's very
interesting because the community is in
some sense it's not a community but
that's a technical error but it's it's
composed of outsiders let's say and what
you notice across the decades is that
the acronym list keeps growing and I
think that's because there's an infinite
number of ways to be an outsider and so
once you open the door to the
construction of a group that's
characterized by failing to fit into the
group then you immediately
create a category that's infinitely
expandable and so I don't know how long
the acronym list is now it depends on
which acronym list you consult but I've
seen lists of 10 or more acronyms and
one of the things that's happening is
that the community is starting to
fragment in its in its interior because
there is no unity once you put a
sufficient plurality under the
sheltering structure of a single
umbrella say the disunity starts to
appear within and I think that's also uh
it's a manifestation of the same issue
that this particular story is dealing
with so that ends I would say the most
archaic stories in the in the Bible
there's something about the flood story
and and also the Tower of Babel I think
they outline the two fundamental dangers
that beset mankind one is the
probability that blindness and sin will
produce a natural catastrophe or entice
one that's something modern people are
very aware of in principle right because
we're all hyper concerned about
environmental degradation and
catastrophe and so that's the continual
reactivation of an archetypal idea in
our in our unconscious Minds that
there's something about the way we're
living that's unsustainable and that
will create a catastrophe it's so
interesting because people believe that
firmly and deeply and but they don't see
the relationship between that and the
archetypal stories because it's the same
story overconsumption greed all of that
is producing an unstable state and
nature will rebel and take us down you
hear that every day in every newspaper
and every TV station it's broadcast to
you constantly so that idea is presented
in in Genesis in the story of Noah and
then the other warning that exists in
the stories one is beware of natural
catastrophe that's produced as a
consequence of blindness and greed will
say the other is
beware of social structures that
overreach because they'll also produce
fragmentation and disintegration and so
it's quite remarkable I think that that
with at the close of the story of the
Tower of Babel we've got most of the
permanent existential dangers that
present themselves to humanity already
identified at the end of the story of
Adam and Eve there's like a fall into
history right so in one way history
begins with the fall but there's like a
second fall I think with the flood and
the Tower of Babel and history and even
more real sense begins now it begins
with this story of Abraham and and it's
it's we're no longer precisely in the
realm of the purely mythical that would
be another way of thinking about it we
have identifiable person who's part of
an identifiable tribe is doing
identifiable things we're in the realm
of history and so history begins twice
in the Old Testament
I suppose it begins again after Moses as
well but we've moved out of the domain
of the purely mythical into the realm of
history with with the emergence of the
stories about Abraham this is from
Aldous Huxley so the first thing that
that I want to talk about in
relationship to the Abrahamic stories is
this idea of the experience of God
because Abraham although quite
identifiable as an actual individual is
also characterized by this peculiar T
and the peculiarity is that God
manifests himself to Abraham both has a
voice and but also as a presence the
stories never describe exactly how God
manifests himself except now and then he
comes in the form of an angel that's
fairly concrete but it's a funny thing
that the author of or authors of the
Abrahamic story seems to take the idea
that God would make an appearance more
or less for granted and so it's very
I think the part of the reason that I've
struggled so much with the Abrahamic
stories is because it's so hard to get a
handle on that and to understand what
that might mean and so I'm going to hit
it from a bunch of different
perspectives and let's see if we can
come up with some understanding of it
the first thing I'll do is tell you a
story about a female neurologist whose
name escapes me at the moment she wrote
a book called my stroke of insight Jill
Bolte I think is her name and she was a
harvard-trained she was she had she had
medical training from Harvard in
neuropsychological function and knew a
lot about hemispheric specialization we
talked a little bit about hemispheric
specialization before one of the ways of
conceptualizing the difference between
the two hemispheres is that the left
hemisphere operates in known territory
and the right hemisphere operates in
unknown territory that's one way of
thinking about or the left hemisphere
operates in the orderly domain and the
right hemisphere operates in the chaotic
domain or the left hemisphere operates
in the domain of detail and the right
hemisphere operates in the domain of the
large picture it's something like that
now people differ in their neurological
wiring so those are over generalizations
but that's okay we live with that for
the time being it's certainly not an
overgeneralization to point out that you
do in fact have two hemispheres and that
their structures differ and if the
connections between them are cut which
could happen for example if you had
surgery for intractable epilepsy that
each hemisphere would be capable of
housing its own consciousness that's
been well documented by a neural neural
neurologist in Gazzaniga who did and
Sperry who did split brain experiments
must be 30 years ago now so and we know
that the right in the left hemisphere
are specialized for different functions
the right hemisphere for example seems
to be more involved in the generation of
negative emotion and the left hemisphere
more involved in the generation of
positive emotion an approach so the
right hemisphere stops you and the left
hemisphere moves you forward
anyways jill bolte I hope I've got that
right at a stroke
and maintained consciousness during the
stroke and analyzed it while it was
happening and she was able well it was
happening to hypothesize about what part
of her brain was being destroyed and
what so she had a congenital blood
vessel malformation and had a nanner
aneurysm and it just about killed her
but she said that it infected her left
hemisphere and she said that she
experienced a sense of divine unity as a
consequence of the stroke because the
left hemisphere function was disrupted
and destroyed and so she became a right
hemisphere dominant and her experience
of that was the dissolution of the
specific ego into the absolute
consciousness something like that now
that's only a case study and you don't
want to make too much of case studies
but there is an overwhelming amount of
evidence that those two kinds of
consciousness exist one being your
consciousness of you as a localized and
specified being and the other being this
capacity to experience oceanic
dissolution and the sense of the cosmos
being one now why we have those
capacities for different conscious
experiences is very difficult to
understand I mean part of me thinks that
maybe we have a generic human brain it's
the brain of the species and allied with
that we have a specific individual brain
and one is the left hemisphere and the
other is the right hemisphere the left
hemisphere being the specific individual
brain and usually it's on and working
because you obviously have to take care
of yourself as a specific entity and not
as a generalized cosmic phenomena it's
hard to dice celery when you're a
generalized cosmic phenomena right so
you have to be more pointed than that
but but look let's make no mistake about
it the fact that those different states
of consciousness exists is not
disputable they can be elicited in all
sorts of ways
and so I'm going to read you something
that eldest Huxley wrote about this back
I think in 1956 this was after he
started his experimentation with
mescaline the psychedelics were
introduced into Western culture in the
1950s in a whole bunch of different ways
psilocybin mushrooms LSD I was
discovered right at the end of world war
two was discovered by accident actually
laboratory Sandoz labs the guy who
discovered it Albert Hofmann had spilled
some on his hands you can absorb it
through your skin and he was biking home
and had the world's first LSD trip which
was somewhat of a shock to him and then
to the entire world Huxley who was a
great literary figure of real genius
experimented with mescaline in the late
fifties and he wrote a book called the
doors of perception which had a huge
impact on the emerging psychedelic
culture both on the East Coast at
Harvard and on the west coast with Ken
Kesey and his Merry Pranksters the
people who popularized LSD that's all
documented in a book called the electric
kool-aid acid test which I would highly
recommend it's Tom Wolfe it's a
brilliant book on the East Coast it was
Timothy Leary I had Timothy Leary's old
job at Harvard so that was kind of cool
you know warped way so I met people
there who knew him who didn't think much
of them also but who did know him but
Huxley had this mescaline experience and
it transported him to this alternative
consciousness and he said that during
his mescaline experience that the entire
world glowed from within like if there
was an inner light like a paradisal
inner light and that everything was
deeply meaningful and symbolically
suggestive and overwhelming and
beautiful and timeless so he had an
experience of divine eternity I suppose
is the most straightforward way to to
put that and we know perfectly well that
the psychedelic drugs that all share the
same chemical structure they interact
with the brain chemical called serotonin
which is a very very fundamental
neurotransmitter they all have
approximately the same range of effects
although those effects are very there's
a very large multitude of effects that
sort of exist underneath that umbrella
Huxley was staggered by his masculine
experience he he didn't really know what
to make of it and I think that that's
the common experience of people who have
exceptionally profound psychedelic
experiences and I'll tell you some
documentation about that in a moment
but he spent quite a long time trying to
come to grips with what this might mean
from an intellectual perspective and
Huxley had a great brain I mean someone
was going to wrestle with the problem
like that he was a good candidate he
must have had a verbal IQ of 180 I mean
he's his books are incredibly literate
incredible credible mastery of language
and complexity of characterization and
and intellectual discourse really
remarkable so this is what Huxley had to
say after his masculine experience he
talked about heaven and hell and he
talked about that in reference to bad
trips essentially because it was known
by that point that a psychedelic
experience could transport you to an
ecstatic domain of divine revelation but
could take you to the worst imaginable
place as well Huxley was very interested
in why you would even have the capacity
for experiences like that and which i
think is a very good question and it's
completely unanswered question I mean we
don't know much about consciousness and
we know even less about psychedelics I
would say they are an absolute mystery I
don't think we understand them in the
least Huxley did a good job of starting
to at least map out the mysteries of the
terrain he said like the earth of a
hundred years ago our mind still has its
darkest Africa's its unmapped Borneo's
and Amazonian Basin Spain in relation to
the fauna of these regions we are not
yet zoologists we are mere naturalist
sand collectors of specimens the fact is
unfortunate but we have to accept it we
have to make the best of it however
lowly the work of the collector must be
done before we can proceed to the higher
scientific tasks of classification
analysis experiment and theory making
like the giraffe and the duck-billed
platypus the creatures inhabit
these remoter regions of the mind are
exceedingly improbable nevertheless they
exist they're facts of observation and
as such they cannot be ignored by anyone
who is honestly trying to understand the
world in which he lives when the
psychiatrist started to study LSD that
was mostly in the late 50s and running
forward from that they thought about the
drug as a psychedelic which was a
chemical substance that would induce
psychosis but that turned out to not be
true not with the psychedelics because
schizophrenic swill given LSD and the
schizophrenic is reported that while the
experience experience was certainly
extraordinarily strange
it wasn't like being schizophrenic and
then it was found later that if you gave
schizophrenic sanphet amines
that made them worse in fact you can
induce a paranoid psychosis in a normal
person by overdosing them with
amphetamines so whatever the
hallucinogens are the psychedelics are
doing it's not the same thing as mania
and it's not the same thing as
schizophrenia not at all so
so you can't just write the experience
off as an induced psychosis whatever it
is independent of its utility or lack
thereof it's not that now can be induced
by drugs can be induced by deprivation
right I mean there are accounts
throughout history of people putting
themselves in extreme physiological
situations in order to induce
transformations of consciousness fasting
is one of the routes to doing that
dancing is another route isolation
prolonged periods of isolation will also
do it
now you could say that exposing yourself
to any of those in excess produces a
state that's indistinguishable from
illness and that there's no reason to
assume that the phenomena that are
associated with illness have any utility
whatsoever although it's interesting to
me that a disrupted consciousness can
produce coherent experiences it's not
exactly what you expect it was just an
illness you know if you develop say a
high fever your experience isn't
transcendent and coherent its fragmented
and pathologized and and the difference
I think is quite distinct although we
don't only we don't have to only
speculate about that because there's
been enough experimental work done
Nellis with hallucinogens and
psychedelics to indicate that the notion
that what they produce is something
that's only akin to pathology is wrong
because it's not a matter of opinion at
this point in the sequence of scientific
and historical investigation in fact
there was a large-scale study done ten
years ago five years ago of two hundred
thousand people who had experimented
with psychedelics and they were mentally
and physically healthier than people who
had meat on virtually every parameter
they examined in fact the rate of
flashbacks you've heard of LSD
flashbacks mostly a hypothetical
phenomena but the rate of self-reported
flashbacks was higher among the non
psychedelic users than among the
psychedelic users
so that was very interesting was a huge
study now it might be you could say that
those who had experimented with
psychedelics were prone to be healthier
to begin with but he that still
contradicts the pathology argument so it
doesn't matter either way
the pathology argument is contradicted
now oh I did put that in it was dr. Jill
Jill Bolte Taylor this is what she said
about her stroke I remember that first
day of the stroke with terrific
bittersweetness
in the absence of the normal functioning
of my left orientation association area
my perception of my physical boundaries
was no longer limited to where my skin
met err I felt like a genie liberated
from its bottle it's good metaphor the
energy of my spirit seemed to flow like
a great whale gliding through a sea of
silent euphoria the absence of physical
boundary was one of glorious bliss
recently if dr. Roland Griffith I met
him once at a conference in San
Francisco surprised surprised a
conference on aw and this was just when
he was embarking on his experiments with
psilocybin which were the first
experiments on hallucinogens that were
permitted by the National Institute of
Mental Health in some three four decades
he had to be very careful to lay out the
scientific protocols so that the ethics
committees would approve the experiments
and so that the federal funding agencies
would also allow the experiments to go
through he started to experiment with
psilocybin and he's found a number of
and published a number of very
interesting results one was that a
single psilocybin trip and I specified
trip because sometimes when people take
psilocybin out the doses that Griffith
uses they don't have a psychedelic
experience most people who take the dose
do but not everyone those who take the
dose and don't have the mystical
experience don't
experience the consequences of taking
the drug
and the consequences can be quite
profound so one consequence is that if
you have the mystical experience that's
associated with psilocybin ingestion
you're liable to represent that to
others and yourself as one of the two or
three most experienced important
experiences of your entire life so that
would be at the same level as the birth
of your child or your marriage let's say
assuming that those were transcendent
experiences but that's but that's how
people describe them so that's that's
very interesting in and of itself then
the next thing that Griffith another
thing that Griffith reported was that
one year after a psilocybin dose a
single psilocybin dose profound enough
to induce a mystical experience the
trait openness of the participants had
increased one standard deviation which
is a tremendous amount and so it looked
like one dose produced a permanent
neurological and psychological
transformation now you know I'm not
saying that that's a good thing I'm not
saying that because I don't think that
openness is a untroubled blessing but
it's certainly a testament to the
unbelievable potency of the of the drugs
there's about a 10% chance by the way
with psilocybin ingestion of a trip to
hell and so that's certainly something
very much worth considering when you're
thinking about the potential effects of
this kind of experience so the the
mystical experience produced by
psilocybin is rated by people as the
most profound among the most profound
experience of their life as
life-changing it produces permanent
personality transformations eighty-five
percent success in smoking cessation
with a single dose right that's another
thing that Griffiths demonstrated now
that is mind boggling because there are
chemical treatments for smoking
cessation
boo Pro prion is one it reduces craving
to some degree but its success rate is
nowhere near
85% certainly not with a single dose and
so we don't understand how it can be
that that occurs but it's nicely
documented by Griffiths team in this
experiment
he gave psilocybin to people who are
dying of cancer cancer patients often
develop chronic clinically significant
symptoms of depression and anxiety
previous studies suggest that psilocybin
may decrease depression and anxiety in
cancer patients
Aldous Huxley took LSD on his deathbed
by the way so the idea that there was
something about psychedelic substances
that could buffer people against the
catastrophes of mortality is an idea
that's as old as experimentation with
the drug itself the effects of
psilocybin were studied in 51 cancer
patients with life threatening diagnosis
and symptoms of depression and/or
anxiety unsurprisingly I don't really
know if it's reasonable to describe the
emotional state of people diagnosed with
cancer of uncertain prognosis or mortal
significance as depression precisely you
know you know what I mean is that if you
go to the doctor and he tells you that
you have intractable fatal cancer the
normative response is to be rather upset
and anxious about that and so it one of
the things that bothers me about
clinical psychiatry and clinical
psychology is the automatic
presupposition that even overwhelming
states of negative emotion are properly
categorized as depression I don't think
you're depressed when you get a cancer
diagnosis I don't think that's the right
way to think about it I think that you
have a big problem and it's not
surprising that you're overwhelmed by
negative emotion and to think about that
as a psychiatric malfunction is a major
error but anyways it's a side issue with
regards to this study
the effects of psilocybin were studied
in 51 cancer patients with life
threatening diagnosis and symptoms of
depression and/or anxiety I cannot
imagine how they got this through an
ethics committee it's just we're going
to take people who have uncertain
diagnosis of cancer that are potentially
life-threatening and we're going to give
them psychedelics it's like but they did
it they did it and I think it's a
testament to Griffiths stature as a
researcher that that that was allowable
this is a randomized double-blind
crossover trial very carefully designed
clinical investigation people were
assigned to the treatment group or the
to the drug group or the non drug group
randomly blindly and investigated the
effects of the drug also with different
doses which is another hallmark of a
well-designed pharmacological study very
low placebo like dose 1 or 3 milligrams
per 70 kilograms of body weight versus a
high dose 22 or 30 milligrams per 70
kilograms of psilocybin chemical
psilocybin administered in
counterbalance sequence with five weeks
between sessions and a six-month
follow-up instructions to participants
and staff minimized the effects of
expectancy participant staff and
community observers rated participant
moods attitudes and behaviors throughout
the study that's also the hallmark of a
well-designed study because they didn't
rely on a single source of information
for the outcome data right they got self
reports that's fine but they had
relatively objective observers also
gathered data at the same time high-dose
psilocybin produced large decreases in
clinician and self related measures of
depressed mood and anxiety along with
increases in quality of life life
meaning and optimism and decreases in
death anxiety that's interesting it's a
subtle and scientifically sparse
statement but it's a very interesting
one it was the in there's a there's an
intimation of a causal relationship here
increases in quality of life life
meaning and decreases in death anxiety I
mean the information there is that one
of the ways of decreasing your anxiety
about death is to increase the
felt meaning in your life and the
psilocybin dosages potentiate that but
it's a good thing to know in a general
manner if it happens to be a
generalizable truth right if you're
terrified of mortality terrified of
vulnerability there's always the
possibility that the life path that
you're following isn't rich enough to
buffer you against the negative element
of existence it's a reasonable
hypothesis and an optimistic one I think
although a difficult one that six-month
follow-up these changes were sustained
with about 80% of participants
continuing to show clinically
significant decreases in depressed mood
and anxiety Steven Ross commenting about
this he was a co-investigator said it is
simply unprecedented in psychiatry that
a single dose of a medicine produces
these kinds of dramatic and enduring
results right which means we have no
idea why this happens
participants in tributed improvements in
attitudes about life / self mood
relationships and spirituality to the
high-dose experience with more than 80%
endorsing moderately or greater
increased well-being in life
satisfaction community observers showed
corresponding changes mystical types
Sylas psilocybin experience on session
day mediated the effect of psilocybin
dose on therapeutic outcomes what that
means is that well when researchers were
trying to look at a causal relationship
between drug ingestion and the positive
outcome the causal relationship was drug
ingestion mystical experience positive
outcome
it wasn't drug ingestion positive
outcome there had to be the experience
produced by the pharmaceutical agent in
order for the pharmaceutical agent to
have had its effect
now we don't again we don't know why
that is either maybe some people needed
a higher dose who knows because people
vary tremendously in their sensitivity
to pharmaceutical substances now why am
I telling you all this
well I'm telling you for a variety of
reasons one is the first is make no
mistake about it human beings have the
capacity for forms of consciousness that
are radically unlike our normative forms
of
consciousness and the evidence that
those alternative forms of consciousness
are purely pathological which is the
simplest explanation right it perturb
the system it produces pathology that's
negative that is the simplest
explanation the evidence for that is
weak at best leaving out the bad trip
issue which which is non-trivial the
empirical evidence as it accrues in fact
seems to suggest that the consequence of
mystical positive mystical experiences
associated with psychedelic intake is
overwhelmingly positive even in extreme
situations and you really can't find a
more extreme situation than uncertain
cancer diagnosis with concomitant and
depression and anxiety like I mean
that's not as bad as it gets but it's
kind of in the ballpark and so the fact
that even under circumstances like that
there is the overwhelming probability
that the experience would be positive
because that's another thing you
wouldn't expect you know even from some
of the earlier earliest discussions
about psychedelic use that were put
forth by people including Timothy Leary
describing the importance of set right
so that the early experimenters noted
that if you had a psychedelic experience
and you were in a bad state or in a bad
place that that was one of the
precursors to a bad trip that the
negative emotion that you entered the
experience with could be magnified
tremendously by the by the chemical
substance and so that it was necessary
to be somewhere safe to be around people
that you trust to be in a familiar
environment to get all the variables
that you couldn't control under control
but here is a situation where that isn't
what's happening at all because people
have this cancer diagnosis of cancer
diagnosis of unspecified outcome and
they still the vast majority of them had
a positive experience and the positive
experience experience had long lasting
positive consequences so so the case
that the transcendent experience is not
real that's wrong it's real now we don't
know what that means because it actually
challenges to some degree our concepts
of what
two dudes real but it's certainly well
within the realm of normative human
experience so it's part of the human
capacity and you know there's been other
neurological experiments too there's
there's a researcher Canadian researcher
for I remember correctly who invented
something he called the god helmet and
it used electro magnetic stimulation
brain stimulation to induce mystical
experiences now I don't remember what
part of the brain he was shutting off or
activating with that particular gadget
but and you know there's also there's
all sorts of other indications of this
sort of thing that have cropped up in
other domains of the neurological
literature for example it's very common
for people who are epileptic to have
religious experiences as part of the
prodrome ah to the actual seizure that
was the case with Dostoyevsky for
example who had incredibly intense
religious experiences that would
culminate an epileptic seizure and he
said that they were of sufficient
quality that he would give up his whole
life to have had them and the funny
thing too is that in my reading of
Dostoevsky at least is that I think that
epileptic seizures and the associated
mystical experiences were part of what
made him a transcendent Lee brilliant
author I don't think that he would have
broken through into the domains of
insight that he possessed without those
strange neurological experiences and it
was certainly not the case that his
epilepsy or the experiences that were
associated with it produced what you
might describe as an impairment in his
cognitive functions quite the contrary
at least that's how it looks to me
here's another here's another something
worth considering and I don't know how
important it is but it might be really
important it depends on how important
this is something that Carl Jung said so
depends on how important Jung is now
Freud established the field of
psychoanalysis and Envisat investigation
I would say rigorous investigation into
the contents of the unconscious a modern
psychologists and psychiatrists like to
what would you say denigrate Freud but I
think there's a reason for that I think
that Freud's fundamental insights were
so profound and so valuable that they
got immediately absorbed into our
culture and now they seem self-evident
and so that all that's left of Freud is
his errors you know because we believed
everything else we believe all the
profound things he discovered we just
take them for granted and so we don't
believe the things that he said that
weren't quite on the money and that's
all we credit with him with now but he
was certainly the first person who
brought up the idea of the unconscious
in a in a rigorous manner and he was the
first person to do a rigorous
examination of dreams the interpretation
of Dreams is a great book it's well
worth reading and he was the first
person to note that people were in some
sense inhabited by subpersonalities that
had a certain degree of autonomy and and
and independent life brilliant
observation the cognitive psychologists
haven't caught up with that at all yet
Jung was profoundly affected by Freud
Jung was profoundly affected by
Nietzsche and by Freud those were his
two main intellectual influences I don't
think one more than the other he split
with Freud on the religious issue that
was what caused the disruption in their
relationship and I think it's an
extremely interesting historical
occurrence and it might be of profound
significance Freud believed that the
fundamental myths of the human being was
the eda pole myth and the eda pole myths
from a broader perspective is a failed
hero story so the eda pole myth is the
myth of a man who develops who grows up
but then accidentally
he comes too close to his mother sleeps
with her he doesn't know who she is and
as a consequence blinds himself and
there's a there's a there's a warning
about human development gone wrong in
that story and I think that Freud put
his finger on it extraordinarily well
because human beings have a very long
period of dependency and one of the
things that you do see in clinical
practice is that many people's problems
are associated with their inability to
break free of their family like they're
consumed by the family drama right they
can't get beyond what happened to them
in their family they're stuck in the
past it's and that's that's equivalent
symbolically speaking you might say to
the idea of being too close to your
mother of the boundaries being
improperly specified and that happens
far more often than anyone would like to
think as I said Freud thought it was a
universal but you see he had a different
idea and his idea was that it wasn't the
failed hero story that was the universal
human myth it was the successful hero
story and that's a big difference like
it's seriously a big difference because
the successful hero's story is
remembering Sleeping Beauty you may
remember this in the Disney movie the
Evil Queen traps the prince in a dungeon
and she's not going to let him out till
he's old right and so there's this
comical scene where she's down in the
dungeon he's all in Chains and she's
laughing at him telling him what his
future is going to be like it's quite
evil and you know she paints this
wonderful picture of him being freed in
like 80 years and hobbling out of the
castle on his his horse that's old it
can barely stand up in him with grey
heron and you know she and she recites
this story of his eventual triumphant
departure from the castle as a old and
decrepit man and she has a great laugh
about it and it's nice you know it's a
real punchy story it's really something
wonderful for children that's story and
he gets free of the of the shackles and
the things that free em are three little
female fairies it's the positive
aspect of the feminine that frees him
from the dungeon so it's very
interesting and very accurate from a
psychological perspective it's the
negative element of the feminine that
encapsulates him in the dungeon and
suppose development of the feminine
would freeze him and and then he has a
the Queen the Evil Queen is not very
happy when he escapes you may remember
that she stands on top of her castle
tower and starts to spin off cosmic
sparks I mean she's quite the creature
enveloped in flame and then she turns
into a dragon and she then the prince
has to fight with her in order to make
contact with Sleeping Beauty and and a
Lincoln her from her comatose existence
as her unconscious existence and that's
a brilliant it's a brilliant
representation of a successful hero myth
he he doesn't end up staying in an
unholy relationship with his mother
let's say he escapes and then conquers
the worst thing that can be imagined and
is Noble by that and not as a
consequence he's able to wake the
slumbering feminine from its coma and
that's a union story and that's the
story that he juxtaposed against Freud
see Freud thought of religious phenomena
as part of an occult tide that would be
they would drown rational rationality
that's why Freud was so dominant Lee
anti-religious and you thought no it's
not the case you're throwing the baby
out with the bathwater there's something
profound and central to the hero myth
and Jung in clinical work is essentially
the awakening of the hero myth in the
analysand
in the in the client or in the patient
to conceptualize yourself as that which
can confront chaos and triumph and that
that's associated with an ennobling of
the of consciousness and the
establishment of proper positive
relationships between male and female
and you know I'm a skeptical person
I'm a very very skeptical person and
I've tried with every trick I have to
put a lever underneath young story and
lift it up and and disrupt it and I I
can't do it I think he was right and
that Freud was wrong I mean I have great
respect for Freud I think he got the
program problem diagnosed very very
nicely and in my clinical work I see the
phenomena that Freud described emerged
continually constantly that the best if
you're interested in that there's a
documentary you should watch I may have
mentioned it before I think it's the
best documentary ever made certainly the
best one I've ever seen it's called
crumb and it's about an underground
cartoonist Robert Crumb who who is part
of a hippie movement and although he
hated hippies he was part of the hippie
movement in the 60s in San Francisco and
started the entire underground comic
what culture that manifested itself
eventually in in graphic novels there's
quite a significant figure from the
perspective of popular art and a very
very intelligent man and also I would
say a hero although a very bent and
depraved and warped one someone very
acutely aware of his own shadow and the
documentary outlines his attempts to
escape from his absolutely dreadful
mother and the failure of his two
brothers to do the same thing one of
whom ended up as a street beggar in San
Francisco the other who drank furniture
polish and died six months after the
documentary was produced it's an
unbelievably shocking documentary it's
the only piece of film that I've ever
seen that captures Freudian pathology
I've never seen anything because you
can't see it generally unless you're in
a clinical situation unless you know the
details of someone's lives the personal
intimate details you cannot communicate
it but the documentaries who made the
film who's Robert Zwigoff if I remember
correctly was a friend of the crumbs and
so he got access in a way that no one
else would have and they were also very
forthright and forthcoming about their
situation in general I would highly
recommend that it's it's a real punch if
you want to know how a rapist thinks
like if
actually want to know because maybe you
don't want to know in fact you probably
don't want to know
right because do you really want to know
that because the understand that means
to put yourself in that position and to
understand it if you really want to know
how a serial sexual predator thinks and
why if you watch crumb and you pay
attention you'll know and that's only a
tiny bit of what the film has to offer
it's really quite remarkable
anyways young split with Freud on the
issue of beautiful story as the
fundamental myth of humankind and on the
issue of the validity of the religious
viewpoint and Jung came down heavily on
the side of the validity of the
religious viewpoint and he established
that in a book called symbols of
transformation which was written in 1914
and that's the book that broke that
produced the break permanent split with
Freud and that book I would say that
books actually been written three times
it was written as symbols of four times
written in symbols of transformation
which Jung extensively revised when he
was all and then it was rewritten in his
innocence by a student of Jung's called
Eric Newman who is also something
someone I would really recommend Eric
Newman I think is Jung's greatest
student and he wrote two books he wrote
one called the origins and history of
consciousness which is a description of
the development of consciousness out of
unconsciousness using the hero myth as a
as an another as a service what would
you say as a as an interpretive skeleton
so we Newman viewed the hero myth as the
dramatized story of the emergence of
human consciousness out of the
surrounding unconsciousness in which it
was embedded the struggle for
consciousness the struggle of
consciousness upward towards the light
like a lotus flower struggles up through
the mock canoe and the water to to lay
itself on the surface of the water and
bloom and reveal the Buddha which is of
course what the lotus flower does from
the symbolic perspective for Norman the
hero's story was the story of the
development success
development of consciousness and the
origins of consciousness the origins and
history of consciousness is a great book
interestingly Camille Paglia
wrote read the origins and history of
consciousness she's one of the few
mainstream intellectuals that I've ever
encountered who read that and commented
on it and she believed that it would be
sufficient antidote to postmodern
denigration of literature she thought it
was that powerful of work and I believe
that I I think it's a remarkable book
Carl Jung wrote the foreword to that
book and he said in the foreword that it
was the book that he wished he would
have written so sort of like byung-hee
wrote I don't remember how many volumes
dozens of very thick difficult volumes
was like Norman was able to what distill
those into a single volume statement and
so I would also say if you're interested
in young the best book to read is the
origins and history of consciousness
it's the best intro into into the
Jungian world seems very difficult to
very difficult to understand it requires
a real shift of perspective in order to
understand what he's talking about
and Norman wrote another book called the
great mother which is a little bit more
specialized in some sense but it's also
extremely interesting because it flashes
out the archetype of chaos and it's
representation as feminine it's a
brilliant book as well and highly worth
highly worth reading both those books
anyways
Young was a very strange person and a
visionary and and so he that's kept him
outside of the academic realm almost
entirely I mean I was constantly warned
as an undergraduate and then a graduate
student and then a professor against
ever talking about Jung in any way
whatsoever when I went on the job market
when I was at McGill
when I had graduated from McGill I'd
done my scientific research in
alcoholism and I had a fairly lengthy
publication record that was pure
empirical research and really neural
physiological research into the
pharmacology of alcohol
and I established a reasonably solid
dossier publications but at the same
time I was writing this book that became
maps of meaning and sorry split my time
and graduate student school between
these two endeavors one very
specifically neurological and
pharmacological and really biologically
based on the other very abstract
religious symbolic psychoanalytic the
complete opposite but I could see that
the two things overlapped really nicely
and there was a number of scientists at
the time that were also drawing the same
conclusions the same relationship
between the biology and the
psychoanalysis Jacques panksepp who
wrote a book called effective
neuroscience which is a great classic is
one of those people who who saw the
relationship between the neurobiology of
emotion and motivation and the
psychoanalytic insights never became a
mainstream view but I think it's too
complex I think that bridging the gap
between the biology and and the symbolic
is too much for people generally
speaking you know it was certainly
virtually too much for me because I got
quite ill when I was a graduate student
I think for a variety of reasons I also
like with glug party three nights a week
and so that probably had something to do
with it but but working on those two
things simultaneously was also rather
exhausting now yone was a tremendously
insightful clinician and he was a
strange person
introverted visionary high in
introversion very very very very very
high in openness like off-the-charts and
also god only knows what his IQ was I
mean every time I read you it's like
reading Nietzsche it's terrifying
because you know he's so damn smart that
he can think up answers to questions
that you don't even it's not like you
don't understand the answers they never
conceptualized the damn questions it's
really something to read someone like
that right who says well here's the
mystery and you think wow I never
thought of that as a mystery and here's
the solution it's like okay that's
that's
that's something you know and he could
read Greek and he could read he read all
the ancient he read a very large variety
of ancient languages and was very
familiar with the entire corpus of
astrological thought and of alchemical
thought and of classic literature and
biblical stories and I mean educated in
a way that no one is educated now and so
he's very daunting person to encounter
and terrifying absolutely terrifying his
book ion which is the second volume of
it's the second volume of volume 9 which
is the archetypes of the collective
unconscious that damn book is just
absolutely terrifying because Jung is
one of these visionaries who can see way
underneath the social structures and
look at patterns that are developing
across for in Jung's case across
thousands of years and lays them out and
so that's a really that's really
something to to encounter ion is a
terrifying book anyways one question
might be well because I read you and I
think how the hell did he know these
things how could he figure these things
out I can't understand how he could
possibly know these things well here's a
partial answer Young was a visionary and
so what that means as far as I can tell
and like we could do a little quick
survey here how many of you think you
think in words put up your hands do you
think in words ok so it looks like what
about pictures how many of you think in
pictures ok so that's interesting how
many of you think that's about half and
half by the way probably a few err on
the word side how many of you think in
pictures and words ok and so alright so
it was roughly 1/3 in each category but
that's also something that I really
haven't encountered any research on from
the neuropsychological perspective it's
like well do you think in pictures or do
you think in words and and is that
actually a reliable distinction I think
I think in words most of the time but I
can think in pictures like if I'm trying
to build something I can think in
pictures very almost instantaneously but
it isn't my natural mode of thinking I'm
hyper verbal and so my
natural mode of thinking is to think
everything through in words but I know
my wife isn't like that she thinks and
images and then has to translate them
into words and so anyways you was very
literate and he could really think in
words but he could really think in
images also talking to my wife quite
extensively like her the intensity of
her visualization vastly exceeds mine so
for example if I close my eyes and then
try to imagine the crowd in front of me
it's pretty low resolution and vague and
not brilliantly colored and vivid you
know it's it's it's like I'm seeing
through a glass darkly let's say I can't
bring images to mind with that with
spectacular clarity but my wife is very
good at that and you seem to be
absolutely a genius at that kind of
thinking and he had a lot of visionaries
in his family history as well so I don't
know to what degree there's a hereditary
component of that and I don't know to
what degree that's actually like a
neurological specialization I presume it
would be associated with the trade
openness distinguishes itself
differentiates itself into interesting
ideas and interest in aesthetics and my
suspicion are is that the people who are
more interested in aesthetics are the
visionary types the ones that think in
images
anyways young could really think in
images and he could imagine beings and I
had a client once who was a lucid
dreamer and how many of you had lucid
dream so you know you're dreaming well
you well you're okay many that's that
phenomena wasn't really even even
identified as a phenomena until the end
of the 19th century there was a book
written about it that Freud tried to get
his hands on but couldn't because it was
a very rare book and then there was a
researcher about 30 years ago who
started to study lucid dreams but
anyways I had a client who was a lucid
dreamer and one of the things she could
do was ask her dream characters what
information they were trying to convey
and they would tell her so that was very
interesting and one of the consequences
of that was I don't have this story
completely right in my memory but it's
close enough she was afraid of a very
large number of things and in her dream
I think it was a gypsy standing by a
wagon told her that if she was going to
be successful in university that she
would have to visit the slaughterhouse
and that was something that was way
beyond her capacity of tolerate she was
a vegetarian she couldn't stand the
sight of raw meat even and so and she
was very oppressed and depressed and
anxious because of the slaughterhouse
nature of existence and so her dream
focused on that and one of the
consequences of that because the
slaughterhouse was out of the question
as a clinical intervention I took her to
an embalming right because because I
asked her I asked her what what what
might be equivalent to that and so she
suggested that and you know exposure
therapy is a hallmark of clinical
psychology right one of the things you
do with people as a clinician is you
find out what they're afraid of and you
gradually and voluntarily expose them to
that and that cures them and that's
associated with the hero myth right it's
exactly the same thing it's like there's
a dragon it's stopping you because
there's lots of dragons most of them
aren't stopping you you can ignore them
you don't have to just go you know slash
away it randomly you're not supposed to
be fighting dragons that aren't in your
way but if they are in your way you
can't ignore them and then you decompose
them into sub dragons and you have
people you know take them on and as they
take them on they dispense with the
dragon and they gain the power of the
drag it's like a video game actually a
video game is like that that's why
people like the video games well that's
right right there's a reason that you
absorb power when you overcome things
when you play a video game it's not like
that's intrinsic to the video game
structure that's an archetypal idea
anyways we went and saw on a bombing
which was a very interesting experience
and and quite quite useful for her
because she knew what she could tolerate
after that and it was a hell of a lot
more than she thought she could tolerate
and so that's very useful to know back
to you
he's a visionary thinker now my client I
said she could lucid dream and she could
ask her dream characters what they
wanted and what they were trying to
communicate to her so that was pretty
interesting that happens spontaneously
had nothing to do with me
I mean I'm interested in dreams and many
of my clients are great dreamers
especially the creative ones because I
think it's a hallmark of creativity to
have vivid dreams and to be able to
remember them but that was a faculty
that was natural to her you had this
other client at one time at one point
and she had a variety of fears and she
had this dream that she told me and she
was walking down a beach and on the side
of the beach up a dune a small dune
there was this old man with a snake a
big Python and there's a crowd around
him and she was walking by the snake
handler and the snake in the crowd and
she didn't want to have anything to do
with them he was sort of showing people
the snake and she told me that dream and
I thought well you know you probably
need to go see that snake and so I
relaxed hers quasi hypnotic technique
and it's very straightforward
hypnosis is generally nothing but
pronounced relaxation well you have to
be susceptible to hypnosis to actually
fall into a hypnotic trance as a
consequence of being relaxed I just
relaxed her I had her breathe deeply and
pay attention to different parts of her
body and just relax her muscles one by
one essentially so that she could
concentrate and then I told her we play
with the dream a little bit it's a union
technique said well so call the dream
image to mind which she could do quite
well said okay so let's let's explore it
it's like pretend it's like pretend play
you know if you're a kid in your pretend
playing you don't exactly direct the
game right you you play the game so it's
partly your direction obviously because
you're the player but the thing also
happens spontaneously out of its own
accord and you can think about that as a
dialogue between the conscious mind in
the unconscious mind in some sense it's
a developmental dialogue it's not a fun
game if you just direct it it's only a
fun game if you're inviting and
something is well
as a consequence the same thing that
happens when you're you're engaged in
some kind of artistic or literary
production if it's all popped down you
know if you're forcing it then it's
propaganda it's empty what you want to
sort of put yourself in a receptive
state of mind in an imaginative state of
mind and it's sort of half you in half
nature itself manifesting itself in your
creative imagination and that was the
sort of state that we were striving for
it she I asked her when she was in
relaxed I said well what do you think
about the snake handler and she said
well he's probably a charlatan and he's
just their turn to impress the crowd and
to show off and she was afraid to go up
there because she thought people would
push her towards the snake and she'd
have to touch it and so there was a fear
of the crowd issue going on there too
and I said well just look go up there
about do it under these conditions is
that you know if people get pushy what
are you going to tell them and so we
figured out something said look just
tell them that you know you want to look
at the snake at your own pace and that
you don't need any encouragement or help
and it would be good if you were just
left alone so that enabled her to defend
yourself so she was afraid that the
crowd would push her to do something
that she didn't want to do that was part
of the theme of the dream so anyway she
eventually climbed the dune in her
imagination and went into the crowd and
the crowd turned out to be quite
welcoming and not hostile and not pushy
which isn't what you'd expect right
because the you'd think the crowd would
have exists reacted in accordance with
her fears since it was her fantasy but
that's the thing about fantasies they
have this autonomous quality but the
crowd was welcoming and not hostile and
it turned out that the snake handler
wasn't a charlatan he was just an old
guy who had this snake and he was out
there just showing it to people because
he thought it was a cool thing and and
and that maybe it was good for people to
come and look at a snake and so she got
close enough to the snake to touch it
and so so I'm telling you that because I
want you to understand a bit more about
what Jung was trying to do and so he
wrote these books notebooks that haven't
been published yet called the Bloch
books and the black books are the
documentation of his experiments with
his imagination and what he would do is
he
dream like a child daydreams he regained
that faculty although I think with you
MIT was a faculty that had never really
disappeared and he had figures of
imagination that came to him that he
could speak with and he spoke with these
figures of imagination and documented
that over a very long period of time and
that was originally that was eventually
distilled into a book called the red
book which was published about three or
four years ago and it was a book that
Jung regarded as the central source from
which all his inspiration emerged it was
sort of the way it looks to me is that
we embody a lot of information in our
action right and our action has
developed as a consequence of imitating
other people and not only the people the
people around us but of course the
people around us imitated the people who
came before them and those people in
metate the people who came before them
and so on so far back that it's as far
back as you can go and so you embody
these patterns of behavior that are
extremely informative that you don't
understand that are a consequence of
collective imitation across the
centuries and so then those patterns can
become manifest as figures of the
imagination and those figures of
imagination are the distillation of
patterns of behavior and so as the
distillation of patterns of behavior
they have content and it's not you that
content it's you could even think about
it as content that's evolves although
it's culturally transmitted this content
that's evolved and so these figures of
the imagination can reveal the structure
of reality to you and that's what
happened with Jung and that's what he
described in the red book and that was
what permeated his psychology a
psychology that was based on the
presupposition that the fundamental
archetypal structures of religious
belief were not pathological not
deceitful not protective in some
delusional sense against the fear of
death but quite the contrary the very
stories that in
abled us to move forward as confident
human beings in the face of chaos itself
and it's conceivable
I think perhaps probable that nothing
more important conceptually happened in
the 20th century than that because it
was the first time post enlightenment
that a rapprochement between the
intellect and the underlying religious
archetypal sub structure occurred you
have in the capacious intellect of young
the same thing happened to some degree
with BSA the religious domain and the
factual domain were brought back
together and the fact of Jung's enduring
and increasing popularity and influence
I would say is a direct consequence of
that now some of his work was spun off
into the New Age and and the New Age is
a very optimistic and naive movement
it's predicated on the idea that you can
do nothing say but follow your bliss and
that will take you ever higher to
enlightenment and that's not the Union
idea at all the Union idea is that what
you most need will be found where you
least want to look so there's this story
King Arthur there's this story of King
Arthur that they're all in a round table
right King Arthur and his knights
they're all equals they're all
superordinate but they're all equals and
they go off to look for the Holy Grail
and the Holy Grail is the container of
the redemptive substance whatever that
is it might be the cup that Christ used
at the Last Supper might be jealous that
was used to capture his blood on the
cross right when he was pierced by a
sword the stories differ but that's the
Holy Grail and the Holy Grail is lost
that's the redemptive substance and the
Knights of King Arthur go off to search
for the Holy Grail and but they don't
know where to look so where do you look
when you don't know where to look for
something you need desperately but I've
lost well each of the knights goes into
the forest at the point of the
darkus to him and that's Jungian
psychoanalysis in a nutshell it's like
that which you fear and avoid that's
what you hold in contempt that which
disgusts you and that you avoid that's
the gateway to what you need to know
there's nothing new age about that
that's for sure now young when he
started this endeavor he started with
this this is part of the notebooks from
the black book he said he wrote my soul
for my soul
where are you do you hear me I speak I
call you are you there I've returned I'm
here again I've shaken the dust of all
the lands from my feet and I've come to
you I am with you after long years of
long wandering I have come to you again
for the aliens the hero's journey is a
journey within and and I think that
that's probably the bias of introverts
to believe that the hero's journey isn't
only an inward journey I think that it
can be an outward journey too because I
don't think it matters where you
confront the unknown whether it's within
or without what matters is whether or
not you confront the unknown that's what
matters but he found that what he had
ignored was an undiscovered part of
himself so that might be something that
was equivalent to Huxley's notion that
there were tremendous tremendous
potential breath in the realm of human
conscious experience and Huxley was
influenced to some degree by you now
young knew of Huxley's experiments and
had commented on psychedelic use and he
said something like beware of wisdom you
did not earn and view was very good at
stating things very profoundly very
simply and that's a very intelligent
piece of advice beware of wisdom you did
not earn he wrote a paper if you're
interested in this sort of thing he
wrote a paper be called the relations
between the ego and the unconscious
which is an absolute
but completely incomprehensible unless
you know what it unless you know what
it's about and what it's about is the
danger of what he called ego inflation
and so one of the things that can happen
as a consequence of a revelatory
experience is that the division between
the individual ego and and and what
would you call it so hard to come up
with a word that isn't somehow naive or
or cliched to erase the relationship the
boundary between the specific
consciousness of the ego and the more
generalized consciousness and more
generalized consciousness as such is a
dangerous thing to do because you can
start to equate yourself your specific
self with that more generalized
consciousness as such and you thought
about that is it something akin to a
psychotic inflation and the paper
relations between the ego and the
unconscious is a document that tells you
how to avoid that if you're playing in
this kind of realm and one of the
injunctions is to keep your feet on the
ground he thought that was what partly
what happened to Nietzsche was that
Michi wasn't grounded enough in life he
wasn't grounded enough in day-to-day
rituals and routines and the mundane now
you could debate whether or not that's
the case whether or not that's a
reasonable argument but that was still
what you believed okay so why am I
telling you all this I'll finish with
this from December 1913 onward Jung
carried on in the same procedure
deliberately evoke a fantasy in a waking
state and then entering into it as a
drama these fantasies may be understood
as a type of dramatized thinking in
pictorial form in retrospect he recalled
that his scientific question was to see
what took place when he switched off
consciousness the example of dreams
indicated the existence of background
activity and he wanted to give this a
possibility of emerging just as one does
when taking mescaline these journals are
Jung's contemporary contemporaneous
clinical ledger to his most difficult
experiment or what
later describes as a voyage of discovery
to the other pole of the world you'll
believe that we were dreaming all the
time but that during waking life the
pressure of external images was such
that the unconscious fantasy imagery was
or that the fantasy imagery was of
insufficient magnitude to be conscious
but that we were always situated in a
dream in relationship to the world so
when we started talking about the
creation of the universe at the
beginning of the Genesis stories I spent
quite a long time setting the stage for
the stories because there's no point in
having a conversation about the God who
gives rise to being unless you have some
sense of what that might conceivably
mean to the modern mind and I felt the
same way about neighbor hammock stories
is I couldn't get a handle on them until
I could understand and articulate more
clearly what it might mean how a modern
person might understand a direct
experience of God in the first question
would be is such a thing possible and
the answer to that seems to be a
qualified yes first of all it's a
universal human experience that's a very
strange thing it's not something that
people have made up as Freud might have
it as a defense against death it's not a
tenable hypothesis it's a realm of
potential experience now that experience
doesn't necessarily have to have the
judeo-christian content that we've been
discussing quite the contrary there are
manifestations of this these alternative
forms of consciousness all over the
world that take on their own peculiar
forms although they're patterned to some
degree that's like the hero myth for
example of myth of the fight against the
dragon seems to be unbelievably
widespread and so it's not as if it's
random sorry I should just see what time
it is here
but there's not much point in having a
discussion about what happens to Abraham
unless you can conceptualize it in terms
that are amenable to modern skeptical
consciousness so we can establish the
proposition that mystical experience is
not only possible it's quite common and
it's inducible in a variety of ways and
the manner in which it's inducible is
reliable and there's no evidence as well
that it's pathological in fact there's a
fair bit of evidence that the patterns
of behavior that are associated with the
mystical experience are core elements of
proper human adaptation in the world
the Abrahamic stories open up with a
manifest God now I'm going to read you
some things from Friedman who wrote the
disappearance of God he was trying to
look at the underlying structure of the
stories now you know Friedman noted that
the books in the Old Testament were
written by a lot of different people at
very different times and then they were
sequenced by other people
for reasons that we don't exactly
understand but there's still an
underlying narrative there's multiple
underlying narrative unities despite the
fact of that rather arbitrary sequencing
and that's a strange thing you know I
guess you could say if you had a
collection of ancient books and you were
trying to put them together you'd try to
put them together in some way that made
sense right and it wouldn't make sense
unless you stumbled across some kind of
underlying narrative that allowed you to
order them and so it's not entirely
surprising that that they're ordered in
a manner that's comprehensible but
Friedman's comments on the underlying
narrative structure part of it was well
we'll go through this the books of the
Old Testament were composed by a great
many authors according to both
traditional religious views in modern
critical scholarship the phenomenon of
the diminishing apparent presence of God
across so many stories through so many
books by so many authors spread over so
many centuries is consistent enough to
be striking impressive and ultimately
mysterious but the hiding of the divine
face is only half the story there's
another development also extending
across the course of the entire
narrative of the Hebrew Bible which we
must see before we can appreciate the
full force of this phenomena and before
we can pose a solution to the mystery of
this of how this happened gradually from
Genesis to Ezra and Esther there is a
transition from divine to human
responsibility for life on earth the
story begins in Genesis with God in
complete control of the creation but by
the end humans have arrived at a stage
at which in all apparent ways they have
responsibility for the fate of the world
the first two human beings Adam and Eve
take little responsibility themselves
they do not design or build anything
when
they're embarrassed over there nudity
they do not make clothes they cover
themselves with leaves it's God who
makes their first clothing for them Noah
by no means a fully developed
personality Noah is not an everyman
either
broadly speaking he reflects a step
beyond Adam and Eve in human character
and responsibility
Abraham beyond the counts of divine
commands that Abraham does carry out the
narrative also includes a variety of
stories in which Abraham acts on his own
initiative he divides land with his
nephew lot he battles Kings he takes
concubines he argues with his wife Sarah
on two occasions he tells Kings that
Sarah is his sister out of fear that
they will kill him to get his wife and
he arranges in son's marriage in the
place of the single story of Noah's
drunkenness there are in the case of
Abraham the stories of man's life be
Abraham section thus develops the
personality and character of a man a man
to a new degree in biblical narrative
while picturing in him a new degree of
responsibility it is not just that
Abraham is kind lured kinder gentler
more intrepid more ethical or a better
debater than his ancestor Noah rather
both the Noah and the Abraham stories
are pieces of a development of an
increasingly stronger stance of humans
relative to the deity before the story
is over humans will become a great deal
stronger and bolder than Abraham
I don't know what that means you know
see it isn't it is certainly the case
that the individual exists in the modern
world the differentiated self-aware self
conscious individual and it's certainly
the case that that wasn't the case at
some point in the past and so it's the
case that there's been a development I
don't know if you could call it a
progression but a development of the
autonomous individual over some span of
historical time now we don't know how
long that's been but my suspicions are
it hasn't been that long I mean I read
once about a Neolithic ceremony that
involved the particular placement of a
bear skull in a cave and then I read
that and they had found these placements
in caves that were at least 25,000 years
old and then I read that they found
caves in Japan among the a new who were
the indigenous inhabitants of Japanese
territory and rather archaic people who
had the same ceremony with the bear and
that put the skull in the same
orientation and place in caves and that
that tradition remained unbroken for
about 25,000 years and you think it well
is it possible for an oral or ritual
tradition to remain unbroken for spans
of tens of thousands of years and the
answer to that is not only is it
possible it's actually the norm because
like one chimpanzee is like the next
chimpanzee right in the in the
progression in the biological
progression if you took a chimpanzee
troop now and he went back 25,000 years
and you looked at a chimpanzee troop
it'd be the same thing there's no
historical progression that's how you
can tell the chimps really don't have
culture because it's bigger it could
even at Crete one one thousandth of a
percent of culture transmissible culture
per generation it wouldn't take more
than about a million years before they'd
have a whole civilization and they don't
they're the same as they were and so the
continuity the stability and unchanging
nature of the species essentially
speaking is the rule that the variant is
us it's like what the hell happened
after the last ice age fifteen thousand
years ago
we went from tribal uniform stable to
whatever the hell we are now it's this
transition from generic to specific it's
something like that and I can't help but
think that that's reflective in this
text and it has something to do with
this transition of consciousness from
from what from possession by the generic
divine to dominance by the specific
individual it's something like that is
that a neurological transformation is
that what this is a record of being that
we don't know one of the things young
said about God because humans
relationship with God as an object of
belief is very complex he in his
technical writing he always talks about
the image of God he never talks about
God he talks about the image of God he
said that the image of God dwells within
that's not the same thing as God
dwelling within right we could mean all
of these capacities that we have for
transcended consciousness could be a
byproduct of biological evolution they
could have no reflection they could have
no relationship whatsoever to an actual
transcendent reality there's no way of
telling the transcendent reality seems
to manifest itself as an element of
experience but that doesn't mean that it
has in reality outside of the subjective
even if it's even if it exists as it is
it clearly does but Friedman suggests
that what's happening in the biblical
narrative is the sequential emergence of
the individual as a redemptive force and
that the Old Testament documents that
implicitly unconsciously as a
consequence of descriptive fantasy and
that that's what's going on in the book
and that so the cosmos is under the
control of generic deity to begin with
something like that and then that
control shifts to localized identifiable
increasingly personal and detailed
individuals you see that in Noah and
then you see the neighbor ham and then
you
moisés and then there's this working out
of what it would mean to be a fully
developed individual and that's what
these stories they're there they're
there they're like prototypes their
attempts to to to bring about the proper
mode of being right and so Abraham is a
is a manifestation about because he
enters into a covenant with God he's
selected by God or enters into a
partnership with God it's not exactly
obvious God provides him with forward
motion and intuition and leads them
towards a successful mode of being and
it's complex successful mode of being
cuz Abraham is a very complex life
there's plenty of ups and downs right
it's it's not unbroken purity of being
towards a divine and Abraham lies and
cheats and deceives and does all sorts
of things that that a real person would
do and and Moses for example kills
someone and so these people that the
biblical people are very genuine
individuals but they're given with all
their faults right with all their sins
with all their deceit they're still put
forth as potential modes of proper
models of potential proper being in the
world and the entire corpus of the Bible
seems to be nothing but an attempt to
keep throwing up variants of the
personality trying to experiment to find
out what personality works in the world
of course from a Christian perspective
that culminates in the figure of Christ
as the redemptive word and that's
associated as we've already talked about
with the force that brought order out of
chaos at the beginning of time and so
well that's my attempt to provide proper
context for the understanding of the
Abrahamic stories and so hopefully with
that context we can move forward
being able to swallow the camel so to
speak of the initial presence of God in
the stories and so we'll return to all
of that next week
[Applause]
let's wait one second okay till people
have an opportunity to leave I would
very much like to ask the people who are
asking the questions to take a few
seconds before they ask the question and
make sure that the mic is positioned
properly so that everyone can hear you
because people keep writing and
complaining that while they're very
happy with the questions and I would say
the questions have been a very high
caliber so far but they're not very
happy that they can't hear them so I
know that you know you're obviously
nervous and in a hurry when you want to
ask you a question but take a second or
two to set the mic up properly and make
sure that everyone can hear you and so
have a way out it blow dr. Pearson hey
there we go
tonight I'd like to ask you about two
different psychological disorders
the first being borderline personality
disorder so two lectures ago somebody
asks you about it and you gave a very
sparse answer I can't remember exactly
what you said but it seemed like it was
uh it would there was too much
complexity to just answer it right there
and then and then somebody else also
acts asked you about the same disorder
in your patreon livestream recently and
when they when they asked you that you
kind of you kind of solved for a moment
and something I don't know something
kind of flicked on in your head it
seemed like and you and you thought for
a couple seconds and then you said you
know what I don't think that I can
answer that right now because just -
it's just too bloody complex and I was
wondering just like many young men have
gravitated towards your lectures do you
think that there's something about this
particular disorder that there's
something about people with this
particular disorder that might gravitate
to your insights and your lectures okay
okay so now I would say probably no to
the second one but I could comment more
about borderline personality disorder I
think I have enough mental energy to do
that tonight
so technically speaking it's often
considered the female variant of
antisocial personality disorder so it's
it's it's it's classified or
it's classified in the domain of
externalizing disorders acting out
disorders and I think what happens we
don't understand borderline personality
disorder very well and it's
characterized by tremendous impulsivity
radical confusion of identity and then
this pattern of idealization of people
with whom the person afflicted with the
disorder is associating with radical
idealization of those people and then
radical devaluation of them and then
there's another theme that sort of
weaves along with it which is the
proclivity of people with borderline
personality disorder to presume that
they will be abandoned and then to act
in a manner that makes such abandonment
virtually certain and so it's a very
complicated disorder but that I think
gets at the crux of it one of the things
that's interesting about people with
borderline personality disorder in my
experience is that they're often quite
intelligent and you you see in the
person with borderline personality
disorder something like the waist or the
squandering of tremendous potential they
seem capable of thinking through the
nature of their problems and analyzing
it and discussing it but not capable
whatsoever of implementing any solutions
and
technically there's no relationship
between I I Q and conscientiousness it's
very weird because if you read the
neuropsychological literature and you
read about the functions of the
prefrontal cortex they're usually
conceptualized in intellectual terms and
they're associated with planning and
strategizing and so forth and that's
what conscientiousness is is planning
and strategizing and implementation but
the correlation between IQ and
conscientiousness is zero and so as the
correlation between working memory and
conscientiousness zero and zero is a
very low correlation right I mean really
it's hard to find things in psychology
that are correlated at zero things tend
to be correlated to some degree they
tend to be interrelated the borderline
seems to be able to strategize and to
abstract but not to be able to implement
and and so this the intellect per se
seems to be functional but it's not
embodied in action
it's very so it can be frustrating to be
associated with someone who has
borderline personality disorder because
they can tell you what the problem is
and even tell you what the solution
might be but there's no implementation
so maybe something went wrong
developmentally we don't know exactly
how these sorts of things come about the
other thing that seems to be
characteristic of borderline people with
borderline personality disorder is that
they they remind me very much of people
who are 2 years old and in some manner
like people with borderline personality
disorder can have temper tantrums in
fact they often do and we know now and
then you see a temper tantrum and
they're usually thrown by two-year-olds
right
most people go out of temper tantrums by
the time they're about three they're
very rare at for it which is a good
thing because if they're still there at
four that is not a good diagnostic
predictor that's a actually good
diagnostic predictor but it's not the
kind that you want and you know it's
funny the way that we respond to
two-year-old temper tantrums because the
two-year-old will throw themselves on
the ground
eat their hands and their legs on the
floor and scream and yell and turn red
or even blue I saw a child once who was
capable of holding his breath during a
temper tantrum until he turned blue
which was really an impressive feat you
should try that right it's really hard
is you really have to work at it and you
see that in adult borderlines they'll
have temper tantrums and the funny thing
is when a two-year-old does it it's like
it's you know it's little off-putting
but when an adult does it it's
completely bloody terrifying and it
happens very frequently with borderlines
and so I would also say to some degree
they didn't get properly socialized
between that critical period of
development between two and four and you
see the same thing with adult males who
grow up to the anti-social because a
large proportion of adult males who grow
up to be antisocial are aggressive as
children as two-year-olds so there's a
small proportion of two-year-olds who
are quite aggressive they'll kick and
hit and bite and steal if you put them
with other two-year-olds it's about five
percent of the of the male's smaller
fraction of the females but most of them
are socialized by the time they're four
but there's a small percentage who
aren't and they tend to stay antisocial
and they tend to turn into long term
offenders and then attend the devel the
critical period for socialization
development seems to be between two and
four and it seems to be mediated by
pretend play and rough-and-tumble play
and those sorts of mechanisms and if it
isn't instantiated by the age of four it
doesn't happen and it doesn't look like
it's addressable now there are dialectic
behavioural therapies that have been
developed for people with borderline
personality disorder and they're
purported to be successful but okay
thank you
if I may so the second psychological
disorder I want to ask you about is
psychopathy so you've mentioned that
Psychopaths
tend to switch from dominance hierarchy
to dominance hierarchy because people
get tired of their shenanigans they have
to move on to fresh people and
Psychopaths also tend to be very low in
conscientiousness and you said that when
you see some of these protesters at your
speeches some of the men in particular
years your clinical intuition tells you
that there's something seriously
pathological about the
and I was wondering if you would suspect
that some of these men might be
psychopathic as well some of them likely
are but I don't know if a higher
proportion of the ones who show up at
protests and sort of creep me out or I
don't know if there's a higher
proportion of people like that at the
protests or not I mean I suspect in
general that regardless of the protest
the proportion of people who have
personality disorders among protesters
is higher than the proportion of people
who have personality disorders in the
general population because you just
expect that you just expect that kind of
acting out behavior
I'm not believe me I'm not saying that
all protest is associated with
personality disorder I'm not saying that
at all there's plenty of reason for
protest but some of the reason for
protests are credible reasons and some
of the more incredible reasons that I
was just thinking that like the social
justice hierarchy so to speak would be
one of the last that these confusing
that's that's that's a different issue
you know there are there are analysis of
the dangers of agreeableness so
agreeable this is a personality trait
that underlies the radical egalitarian
ethos because agreeable people want
everything to be shared equally and it's
a good I think it's a good ethos for a
small group for a family because family
is kind of a communist system in some
sense right it's like you want the food
to be divided up equally among the
children clearly and you want all the
children sort of regardless of their
inherent abilities to have the same
opportunities and perhaps even the same
outcomes so I think agreeableness which
is associated at least in part with
maternal maternal the maternal instinct
let's say maternal patterns of behavior
I think it's it's a good first pass
motivational approximation to a
localized familial ethic I think it's a
catastrophe at larger scales I don't
think it scales at all I actually think
that's why we evolved conscientiousness
because conscientiousness is the
principle that allows larger scale
organizations to exist agreeableness
won't do it now conscientiousness is a
mystery right we don't have a
neurological model we don't have a
conceptual model we don't have an animal
model we don't have a pharmacological
model
and we really only have one way of
assessing it which is self and other
reports of personality proclivity so
anyways the problem with agreeableness
this is be modeled a game theorist is
that a population of cooperative people
can be dominated by a single shark so
agreeable this is insufficient as a
principle because it opens itself up to
you call that manipulation and
manipulation let's let's leave it at
that to manipulation and and and and
exploitation that's the other thing
exploitation so thank you hi dr. Pearson
I had one quick comment and aggression
so my comment was about your idea of but
subpersonalities as one-eyed monsters
now there's the idea of multiple
personality or split personality
disorder it's controversial as to
whether or not it exists but there's
some research recent research that
suggests that you may actually have
multiple personalities that use
different parts of the brain so they
have differential access to the
hippocampus they have their own memories
they can date they use the brain
differently but that seems to be an
exaggeration of armed sub personalities
which is quite interesting um the
question I had was about so you talked
about young and how you should confront
that which you don't want to confront
the most so you're most afraid or
disgusted by that you've the most
resistance to arm so but we were talking
about psychedelics and in the experience
of Hell so at least some of the people
I've talked to they describe negative
trips as an experience of a constant
fear prolonged fear and some of the most
dramatic and personalized fear
that they've ever experienced or
shouldn't negative on
psychedelic trips elicit the kind of
concentration that young thought you
should engage them could be could could
well be you know it it's conceivable
that I read this strange book once that
made the claim that what was in the Ark
of the Covenant was a mixture that was
made from Amanita muscaria mushrooms and
that's not as far-fetched as you might
think because there's a mycologist and
amateur in it mycologist named Gordon
West saw who established credibly the
notion that it was Amanita muscaria
potions that was the soma of the Rig
Veda and so it's a strange idea but it's
not an idea that's completely outside of
the realm of possibility and the Amanita
muscaria is the fly agaric in the red
mushroom with white dots and it's used
in shamanic rituals in cross Asia and
it's apparently not toxic in its dried
form although that is not a
recommendation you know this is serious
serious and dangerous speculation and
material one of the things that the
priests had to do before they commune
with what was ever in the Ark of the
Covenant was purify themselves and so
one possibility is that the bad
psychedelic experience is a involuntary
confrontation with what you would
describe as the shadow it's like so
beware of experimenting with substances
that produce divine revelations if
you're in a serious state of disorder
and I do think that is what happens to
people is that they encounter everything
about them that's chaotic and out of
place and some people get trapped in
that and they can't get beyond it and
that's because there's so much of it and
so but we don't know enough to know so
[Applause]
citizen Peterson you son of a [ __ ]
how are you I'm not too bad you got a
question that's the question no I've got
a real question I got a great question
you're going to like this one okay it's
about inspiration because you talk about
inspiration quite a bit in this lecture
series and also I wanted to point out
you have a I guess a 45-minute armchair
discussion which you have a video of one
paragraph of Nietzsche's Beyond Good and
Evil ya posted and it seems like you're
awestruck at the structure and the
choices and I guess the ideas contained
in various layers of this paragraph and
you're inspired and that inspires you to
I guess do your work that you do I
encountered I guess a similar phenomenon
here with one sentence written by the
great Joseph Cardinal Ratzinger and I
mean this one sentence answers the
question why do people search for God
and if you could read it out and then
deconstruct it it's once
it's at the end of page 105 if you want
to read it from the book or I just
that's the question that human existence
not only poses but itself is the in
conclusiveness inherent in it the bounds
it comes up against and that yet yearn
for the unbounded more or less in the
sense of Nietzsche's assertion that all
pleasures yearns for eternity it
experiences itself as a moment this
simultaneity of being limited and of
yearning for the unbounded and open has
always prevented man from resting in
himself made him sense that he is not
self-sufficient but only comes to
himself by going outside himself and
moving toward the entirely other and
infinitely greater well it's a hell of a
sentence like when I read that sentence
I decided I wanted to write like Joseph
Cardinal Ratzinger I had a very similar
experience when I watched the Jill Rogan
podcast 877 I said I want to speak like
Jordan Peterson that's what I wanted to
do so I had this concur I had this
discussion with a patreon supporter this
week
a young guy from Australia and he said
something very interesting that's
related to this and it's a bit it's
something that's very profound I said I
think there's this idea in Christianity
that we've discussed briefly that the
judge and the Redeemer are the same
figure now you know in the book of
Revelation you may know this and you may
not Christ comes back as a judge he has
a sword coming it's a it's a revelatory
vision not that that book it's a very
strange it's the last thing you'd expect
conservative Christians to believe and
believe me and such a visionary
hallucination the book of Revelation but
Christ comes back with a sword coming
out of his mouth and he comes back as a
judge and he divides the Damned from the
redeemed and most are damned and some
are redeemed it's very very harsh young
believed that the figure of Christ in
the Gospels was too agreeable to
merciful to tilted towards mercy and
that that called out for a counter
position and that
the counter position of judgment very
interesting hypothesis but then but then
there's this this melding of the two
ideas that the judge and the Redeemer
are the same thing
okay now this young man told me that his
life lacked purpose and direction and
meaning and that he was nihilistic until
he started he read then in the art of
motorcycle maintenance which is a book I
actually like quite a bit I've read it
three times at different decades of my
life and one of the things that's very
interesting about that book is that it's
an examination of the idea of quality of
the idea that there are qualitative
distinctions between things and that we
have an instinct to make qualitative
distinctions and so a qualitative
distinction is simply this is better
than that which is a judgment okay now
what rap singer is hypothesizing is that
the person in enough you know how you
the idea of the modern idea is you're
supposed to accept yourself
I think that's an insane idea by the way
really I think I can't think of a more
nihilistic idea than that you're already
ok it's like no you're not and the
reason you're not is could you could be
way more than you are so what do you
want to be you want to be ok as you are
or do you want to strive towards what's
better and this young man this
Australian he said that the reason that
zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance had such a impact on him was
because he wasn't happy with his current
mode of being right he didn't consider
the manner in which he conducted himself
sufficient and the fact that the author
of zen and was persik laid out the
notion that you could make qualitative
distinctions and there really was a
difference between good things and bad
things or great things and evil things
it gives you direction it gives you
gives you the possibility of moving
upward and Ratzinger is pointing out at
least to some degree that human beings
are insufficient in and of themselves
and need the movement upward and so they
need to conceptualize something like the
highest good and then to strive for that
and the thing is is that there isn't any
difference between conceptualizing the
good and being judged
because if you're going to conceptualize
the good and move towards it what you
have to do is separate from yourself all
those things that aren't good and leave
them behind and that's where the
Redeemer and the judge are the same
thing and one of the things that's
really appalling I think about our
modern world is that we're rejecting the
notion of qualitative distinctions you
say well we don't want to hurt anybody's
feelings by saying that one thing is
better than another it's like okay fair
enough it's not fun to be cast off with
the Damned that's for sure but if people
are in fact insufficient Internet in
their present condition which seems to
be the case we try finding someone who
isn't then if you deny the possibility
of qualitative distinction because you
want to promote a radical egalitarianism
then you remove the possibility of
redemption because there's no movement
towards the good and it seems to me that
it's a catastrophe to sacrifice the good
for well it's a catastrophe to sacrifice
the good for they equal because for us
to be equal would be mean as far as I
can tell that we would all be equally
unredeemed and miserable and so he also
mentioned in the previous paragraph I
believe that even in the case when you
experience the human life at its fullest
that it's most beautiful as its most
meaningful you have a deep I guess
understanding that you have something to
be thankful for you need to thank
somebody for that it's not based
entirely on your own merit and that
points you towards something else and
also and I don't think that you can have
a profoundly positive experience you
know in the best sense without that
accompanying it that's a feeling of
being blessed it's something like that
yeah that's a good oh wait hold it I'm
going to stop you okay because I'm going
to ask this person but I would like to
say that those were remarkably good
questions so
[Applause]
experience and thank you for the
wonderful lecture given your working
definition of truth and and let's say
within the Abrahamic religious tradition
would you say that the more perhaps
mystical sects and denominations which
play plays more emphasis on the
transcendental experience of God also on
this experience as opposed to the more
fundamentalist Orthodox literalist which
perhaps emphasize that what I've noticed
moral policing of behaviors yeah would
you say that the former is more true
than the latter no and you know and and
okay sorry continue to and be we could
the former in some ways serve as an
antidote to extremists little ISM
jihadism fundamentalism okay so yes to
the second part but the first part it's
great to great question we did say we
did some research on this a while back
because we're looking at the different
religious proclivities of liberals and
conservatives and liberals like if
you're liberal it means you're high in
openness and low in conscientiousness
and if you're conservative then you're
high and conscientiousness and low and
openness and that the liberals are
spiritual and the Conservatives are
dogmatic but it's best to think of those
as partners right because the spiritual
mystical end is where the revelations
emerge and the renewal but that's where
there's chaos and and discord as well
because what's new disrupts what's
stable and so what's new has to be
turned into it has to be integrated into
what's stable and so you need both those
poles and of course if the dogma to skip
the upper-hand then everything turns
into a tyranny of stone that that's
Egypt in the Old Testament but if the if
the if the Mystics get the upper hand
then everything floats off the earth
into some impractical ether that is
equally counterproductive and so there
has to be a dialogue between those
different poles and I think you see that
in the distribution of human
temperament you know the conscientious
types there they tend to be orderly the
orderly types tend to tend towards kind
of a right-wing totalitarianism that's
their proclivity when they when they
when things get out of hand especially
if they're low in openness that's a
danger but you see the same thing with
the people who are too open and not
conscientious at all they're dreaming
all the time but they never do anything
there's never anything implemented and
that that's bad
that's a bad thing so I don't think that
you can say that like the dogmatic
structure is necessary because that
perpetuates the system and the
revelatory element is necessary because
that renews it when renewal is necessary
and there has to be a continual dialogue
between those elements so that neither
of them fall prey to their own
particular form of pathology that's one
of the problems with the current
political what would you call it
polarization that's occurring across the
West is that the right and the left and
are talking to each other anymore that's
a very bad thing because the left will
wander into a pit and fail without
boundaries and the right will enclose
itself in smaller and smaller spaces
until it can't move without the left and
one of the reasons that democracy works
is because it makes people talk or
allows them to talk you can have it
either way but it's in its bits because
every virtue has its vice right and so
in a meta virtue is something like the
amalgamation of singular virtues into
something that's a transcendent
structure that has more to do with the
harmony of virtues rather than with any
given virtue even though I think that
freedom of speech is the clearest
manifestation of that harmony of virtues
so and so all could be a lubricant for
the beginning of this discussion do you
think between the liberals and
conservatives
I don't know how to answer that it
doesn't follow immediately from your
from your initial presupposition so the
all experience is a different issue yeah
we'll be able yes at least exposing
conservatives to some form of that
experience could it be if we requisite
for a more productive dialogue see I
mean in it in in in the church in church
ceremony let's say a classical church
ceremony there's some intermingling of
both right you mean you think about a
church ceremony that takes place in the
Gothic cathedral we've certainly got the
dogma and they're under and the
relatively rigid rule structure but at
the same time that's aligned with
intense beauty and in the architectural
forms in the in the light that's
streaming in through the stained-glass
windows and the music and I mean the
Gothic cathedrals are forests right it's
a stone forest with sunlight streaming
in through the trees and it's a balance
between structure light there are
absolutely unbelievable structures and
they speak of the transcendent but but
inside that there's a structure and so
it seems that in order for the religious
impulse to be balanced properly there
has to be a reasonable dialogue even in
practice between the mystical or
inspiring transcendent and the dogmatic
yeah either of those can can go as
either those goes astray without the
other if you're too dogmatic do you need
aw likely yes because that would show
you that there's something beyond your
own presuppositions so so oh I should
tell you something interesting about awe
as a as a physiological phenomena you
know how you're listening to music and
you get chills
some people experience that more than
others open people experience that more
or music is a pretty reliable elicitor
of chills that's PI low erection that's
your hair standing on end you see a cat
when it sees a dog puffs up that's all
it's the same thing like that that chill
is your hair standing on end and that's
this that's
sensation you get in the presence of a
meta predator it's something like that
and so the our experience is a I mean
obviously it's become very cognitively
and emotionally complex in human beings
but it's fundamental evolutionary
underpinning is the instantaneous pilo
erection that you see in prey animals
when they're confronted by a predator
and of course that would be if you are a
rabbit you can bloody well believe that
you see a wolf and it would inspire awe
that's for sure I mean if a wolf that
was 20 feet high came bounding in here
man
you'd feel awe so yeah that will
convince you that there's something that
you still need to know last last
question perfect timing
hi dr. Peterson my name is Gary and I'm
a clinical and counseling master student
right now and so one of the key ideas
that's been surfacing time and time
again in your lectures is the idea that
phenomenology is structured and flows
mythologically and the way that plays
out is I'm supposing effectively just
pay attention to what comes up kind of
naturally and you can locate the chaotic
elements in your experience and product
them with whatever degree of necessity
you think so
chyna situate this within the clinical
context we can conceptualize
psychotherapy as a kind of guided
journey just as you touched on in this
lecture where it's more of a meta
journey in a sense a meta heroic journey
if I don't know how you want to think
about it but just for those of us who
are interested in kind of grounding and
implementing these ideas within
psychotherapeutic practice what should
we watch out for in the process itself
what comes up what should we be afraid
of or fearful of or cautious about or
what should we tend towards that's my
question well I think one of it one of
the people who I've read that's had the
biggest impact on me as a clinician was
Carl Rogers
and the reason for that is that Carl
Rogers put tremendous emphasis on
listening like it's almost impossible to
overestimate how useful it is to listen
to your clients like you need a meta
scheme in some sense and the meta scheme
I think is laid out in the Sermon on the
Mount it's something like orient
yourself and your client towards the
good the client has to conceptualize
what that might be you can serve as a
guide but it has to come from that
person because one of the things that
you want to find out from your client is
okay what's wrong they have to tell you
and what would not having something
wrong look like like what is it if you
could have what you wanted and that and
that that would be good what would that
look like okay so that establishes your
star right it's like Geppetto
establishing the relationship with the
star at the beginning of Pinocchio
here's what we're aiming at okay so now
you've got that schema here's what we're
aiming at now you might say you might
think well now that what happens to the
client is they meet their dragons along
the way and the Dragons would be well
now you know what you want and there are
things in your way and some of those
things might many of those things are
going to be intensely practical but
they're practical / psychological so
like so maybe someone is has a job and
they would like to move forward in the
job but they're terrified of speaking in
public well you know is that a
psychological problem or a practical
problem it's both it's also a real
problem in many positions unless you can
speak fluently publicly you're you're
going to hit a ceiling and you're not
going to go anywhere and so for the
person to move towards that goal then
they have to confront the obstacles that
manifest themselves within that
framework and part of your job as a
clinician is to identify the obstacles
and to discriminate them from things
they don't have to worry about right
part of it is you know you can't just
run around and try to combat all the
chaos in the world some of it is your
chaos and a bunch of it isn't and the
chaos that's yours is the chaos that
emerges as you move towards a necessary
goal and so partly what you're doing by
listening to your
is to help them cut their dragons down
to size you know because what will
happen if you start to talk to somebody
about public speaking and you really
talk to me is that you decompose the
problem into a set of maybe 20
subproblems like well do you know
exactly how to give a speech like what's
your theory of public speaking you know
how to look at people when you're
talking do you know how to speak loudly
enough so that people can hear you do
you have a philosophy of public speaking
you know those things are necessary in
order to do it properly you need to
decompose that with the client and then
to make those problems you have to
decompose them to the point where they
can be met by a practical solution and
then you have to guide the person
through the implementation of the
practical solution and mostly you do
that by by listening it's like the what
you need to be is the person who helps
the person that you're working with
orient themselves towards a better
future
that's the compact you and I are in this
space at this time to make things better
first of all we have to decide what
better would look like and second we
need a strategy and third we need to
once we have that we're going to see the
obstacles and some of those are going to
be psychological and some of them are
going to be practical and we're going to
engage in joint problem-solving of
whatever sort is necessary in order to
minimize the impact of those problems or
to gain from the problems and dream
analysis can be extremely useful for
that by the way it's even more useful
for helping the person identify what the
goal is because that's often difficult
for people it's like well I know that
something's wrong but I don't know what
I want sometimes people get so stuck
there that they just can't get they just
can't get out of it
so and then what would you watch out for
now I'm not neurologically the way it
shows up the way it's experienced well I
would say the clinician one of the
things that you should watch out for is
resentment so there's a there's a couple
of rules of thumb that I think are
useful don't do anything for your
clients that they can do for themselves
and don't do them any favors now I think
you can step beyond the confines of your
role carefully now
and then to show that there's there's
there's a more human connection than the
merely contractual I think that's very
useful but their problems are not your
problems you do not have any right to
their problems and so you have to
maintain that detachment because
otherwise you can steal their destiny
you don't want to be the person that
solves their problems because you steal
their destiny when you do that you want
to be someone with whom they can figure
things out for themselves and so there
can be hubris in being a clinician
because you can be the problem solver
and that elevates you to a position you
elevate yourself to that position you'll
fall flat on your face you'll hurt your
clients and things will kick back on you
very very hard because what the hell do
you know right nothing because that
person is very complicated and they need
to they need to sort themselves out and
but you can be a facilitator for that
but that's all you should be and so you
have to watch that you have to watch
over becoming over and K over ly
entangled so you have to maintain your
detachment in the best sense and you
have to not overstep your it's easy to
become hubristic when the person is
looking to you for the answers it's like
you might you don't have the answers
although you might be able to find help
the person find their way that's what
you do with everyone you love - right I
mean you don't provide them with the
answers because then they become little
clones of you and unhappy bitter
resentful and angry little clones of you
because you usurped their destiny and so
the same thing applies within familiar
arrangements or friendships all about it
so
[Applause]